Малышка . Hamburg! Schön, dass ihr da seid! Wow! Holy crap! Wow, hey! Meine Herren, herzlich willkommen Hamburg! Ich darf euch vorstellen, Stefan Tietze! Er ist hier in diesem Raum, der es heute auf Auslandsweisen beeinrichen konnte, ist ich, Fluchanfien zu Ausland. Danke schön zu Ausland, vielen Dank. Fantastisch, wow! Schön, dass ihr da seid. Ich bin ein bisschen außer Atem, ey. Wir haben zu viel getanzt kurz vorm Auftritt, ehrlich gesagt. Ich finde, es war ein bisschen außer Atem. Weil die ersten Intros laufen, und man kennt die mittlerweile, da haben wir so eine kleine Kurier ausgedacht und tanzt die ganze Zeit rum. Aber das ist nicht in Form zum Tanzen. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Ich weiß auch nicht, warum es sich durchgesetzt hat, dass man an dem Ort, an dem man tanzt, in Clubs und Discos, auch Leute anspricht, wo man eigentlich in der Regel von der Tanzwelt kommt. Ja, das ist Social Get-Together-Obsch. Ich wollte nur sagen, du bist ein bisschen was. Und vor allem, jetzt sehe ich hier, kennst du das, wenn du so weisst, dass du gleich aufstoßen musst?
Ja, natürlich. Man spricht ja auch anders.
Und das über so zwei, drei Wochen in der Welt, einfach so, ich weiss, gleich kommt's. Und so war es bei mir auch gerade.
Und ich will schon mal vorwarnen.
Deswegen bist du so aufs Klo gerannt.
Dann noch kurz vorhin.
Ich will schon mal vorwarnen, irgendwann während dieser Folge werde ich aufstoßen.
Kennst du das? Das ist ganz schwierig. Ich habe einen Kollegen, der hat andauernd so einen kleinen Klos im Hals und spricht dann aber weiter. Und das ist das Unangenehmste der Welt, weil ich habe noch nicht die richtigen Worte gefunden, um ihm zu sagen, dass er das bitte verdammt noch mal wegräuspern soll. Und mein Trick ist dann immer, wozu ich dann greife, ist dann immer ein, äh, nee, der nervt mich auch mega. Die einzige Strategie, die man in der Situation hat, ist davon auszugehen, dass dein Gegenüber noch nie was von Reusmann gehört hat und man es ihm einfach vormacht und einfach sagt, du, der menschliche Körper ist zu folgendem in der Lage. Ja, wenn man sagt sowas wie, ich habe gerade auf zufälliger Wikipedia-Artikel geklickt, Reusmann, auch so geht es da. Komisch, ne? Wollen wir mal alle Worte mit R sagen vielleicht? Wollen wir mal alle zusammen räuspern vielleicht? Hier ist auch ein Soundbeispiel. Können wir alle mal räuspern auf drei? Eins, zwei, drei! So, guck mal. Jetzt können ja schon mal alle, die diesen Podcast hören, können jetzt schon mal abräuspern, einfach in der U-Bahn. Falls ihr jemanden in der U-Bahn seht, der räuspert, einfach das Podcast-Ufo-Zeichen machen, das ich gerade mache. Das können die Zuhörer leider gerade nicht sehen. Kennst du das bei Rockbands, wenn die bei Rockbands, können auch die Zuhörer nicht sehen, aber das ist immer so geil, wenn die sich immer so auf die Monitore lehnen und dann immer weiter singen. Aber ich trau mich, das habe ich gerade nicht getraut, ich habe kurz überlegt, das zu machen, weil es bequem ist, das Bein hochzustellen, aber das wählt sich dann so. Und das zeichnet, glaube ich, Punkbands aus, die scheissen da einfach drauf, die stellen einfach den Fuss darauf, ich habe da so viel Angst vor. Ich dachte aber, das sind immer Ermüdungserscheinungen, weil natürlich hat so ein Kid-Rock auch mal so ein ... Nee, das will sie sich draufsetzen. Stimmt, weil sieht man selten irgendwie, dass Leute wirklich durchschnaufen auf der Bühne, so eine Adele, die auch mal so ... Vor allem Adele! Oder gähnen, Leute gäh so, bei Sudokus sagen die auch immer, man nimmt irgendwie zehn Kilo ab pro Konzert oder so. Ja, wirklich? Sagen die immer, wo man sich auch immer fragt. Dann isst die aber sehr viel danach, also zwischen Konzerten. Ja, ja, okay. Frau Adele. Verstehe, verstehe. Man isst danach zehn Kilo und sagt, boah, da bin ich jetzt auf null wieder raus. Da war ich eine gute Idee. Ich habe das aber bei Torwarten gehört, weil ich hatte lange... Torwarten? Ich habe keine Ahnung von Fussball und deswegen waren die Torwarten langes kipptisch. Hast du gerade gesagt? Also du hattest keine Ahnung von Fussball? Ja. Ich freue mich aber, wenn ich am Ende der Story angelehnt, dann wo kam dann die Erleuchtung her? Als ich diesen Fakt gehört habe, weil ich dachte, lange Torwarte sind überbewertet, die stehen nur rum das ganze Spiel, aber irgendwann hat Olli Kahn mal gesagt, allein wegen dem Stress nimmt er in so einem Spiel fünf Kilo ab. Nur weil er so gestresst ist, so viel Druck und Kinder abholen nach dem Spiel. Ich habe auch McDonalds-Gutscheine für einen Fish Mac, heisst der Fish Mac so. Ich glaube, du denkst auch viel nach in so einem Tor. Ich glaube, wenn der Ball so auf der anderen Seite ist, denkst du dir, neblig, keine Ahnung, und dann kommen so die Gedanken irgendwie, was habe ich noch für Gutscheine in der Schublade.
Das ist auch für mich sehr verwirrend, als Kind sieht man dann immer, weil ich mal Stadion und dann beobachtet man diese Dinge, die man sonst im Fernsehen nicht sieht.
Und am Anfang, wenn ein Torwart, dann gibt es ja irgendwie dann in der Mitte, dann gibt es ja am Anfang dann so, wird der Münchshof, entscheidet dann, wo gespielt wird, wo nach wo, und dann läuft der Torwart immer schon so, dann macht der noch ein bisschen warm und läuft dann so in sein Tor rein und dann legt er immer seine Trinkflasche ins Tor, falls er Durst bekommt. Das ist vielleicht auch immer cheatend. Finde ich auch. Ja, weil er ist der, der sich wenigstens bewegt, aber der auch zwischendurch einfach zu der Trinkflasche greifen kann, trinken kann, damit er seinen grossen Patsche-Handschuhen das zumachen kann und er weglegen kann. Aber das ist gemein allen anderen Spielern gegenüber, die sehr viel rennen müssen. Vor allem auch zu den Handschuhen, es gab ja irgendwann mal wenig Regeln für Fussball, mittlerweile gibt es viel, aber es muss irgendwann ein Tor gegeben haben, der eines Tages auftaucht. Problematisch ist es halt, wo es keine Tore gab. Und der eines Tages aufgetaucht ist, zum Spiel einfach so riesige Handschuhe hatte, so riesige Mickey Maus und der Schiedsrichter so, steht nichts in den Regeln, Leute, wir müssen jetzt dieses eine Spiel so spielen, danach können wir die Regeln ändern.
Das Regelnbuch war damals noch so ein Flyer und er hat immer so nichts. Einfach so riesengroße Hände die ganze Zeit. Einfach nichts als Geheimnis. Manchmal gibt es so ein Sketch, ging mal viral, den ich ganz clever fand, wo einfach sehr viele in dieser Römer, hier ist Astrid-Schloss-mäßig, Schildkröten-Taktik einfach als ganze Mannschaft diesen Ball beschützen und so langsam Richtung Tor bewegen und die anderen Spieler dann auch ab und zu so reingrätschen, dann irgendwann auch anfangen zu treten, weil irgendwas ist für ein Wider-Scheiss, der gerade passiert, dann aber eine gelbe Karte bekommen, das Team kriegt dann wieder einen Freistoß und macht das weiter. Und es ist sehr langsam und langweilig, dieser Sketch auch, ist auch nicht lustig gewesen, einfach nur clever. Und dann am Ende war der Ball im Tor. Das sind dann Wissenschaftler, glaube ich. Ist Wissenschaft eigentlich uncoole Comedy? Ich glaube schon, wo die Pointe irgendwo vergessen wurde. Die Pointe ist erstaunlich, aber nicht lustig. Das stimmt schon. Und dann war halt Tor und man denkt sich, ja, aber warum ist das nicht erlaubt und macht das überhaupt Sinn? Ja, wir hatten auch damals in der Schulklasse dann natürlich Fußball und man wird nicht gewählt und am Ende bleiben die drei Fetten übrig. Und dann schafft man es aber trotzdem, weil der Trainer der anderen Mannschaft einfach klüger ist, dass alle drei Fetten in einer Mannschaft sind. Und man guckt sich an und schüttelt so den Kopf einfach so, das wird nichts, wir werden gnadenlos verlieren und dann aus dieser underdog situation kommt aber ein gewisser ehrgeiz zu sagen nee wir wollen gewinnen und dann haben wir uns teilweise wie viel drei fetten alle ins tor gestellt einfach weil wir gesagt haben wir machen das beste aus unserer situation und stellen uns einfach ins tor und es war fantastisch es war wirklich gut es sind aber auch keine grossen Tore muss man auch zu ihrer Verteidigung sagen also die Idee ja deshalb auch gut, weil das so Hockey-Tore sind, so kleine. Die füllst du ja schon aus, wahrscheinlich als Kind. Nee, weil du wurdest ja damals auch die Fette genannt. Der Name musste ja auch irgendwo herrühren. Ich bin nicht sportinteressiert, aber ich schaue mir dann gerne so Compilations an. Das ist eigentlich mein Sport. E-Sport-Compilations aber dann auch. Ja, aber auch echte Sport. Und da gab es so eine Situation, so die gr jahr des jahrzehnt sogar und da gab es dann einen so ein eishockey-Torwart und dann kam so der andere Eishockey-Spieler mit seinem mit seinem Löffel da an und kam da an und sagt ich will jetzt dieses Tor schiessen womit schiesst man das Tor was muss jetzt richtig oder halbrunde diesen Krakending da und dann kommt er an und sagt ich will jetzt dieses Tor unbedingt schiessen, ich will da rein und dann läuft er, fährt er aber alleine, gleitet er quasi auf das Tor des Eishockey-Torwarts zu
und der Eishockey-Torwart entscheidet sich, nee, so machen wir das hier gar nicht und macht sein Tor kaputt und nimmt das Tor und reißt es so runter,
weil dann gibt es einen Strafstoss, aber der Angriff ist erst mal abgebrochen.
Und dann kriegt er einen Strafstoss, aber er sagt, okay, der kommt alleine auf mich zu, entweder ich versuche den Puck zu halten oder ich mache mein Tor kaputt.
Ja, aber dann ist das Tor kaputt und hat dann den Strafstoss gehalten.
Und wie hat dieser Footlocker Schiedsrichter reagiert?
Er hat dann gesagt, ja stimmt, steht in den Regeln, PDF aufgemacht, irgendwie, Adobe Update.
Command F, Tor verschoben. Ich weiß, Tor verschoben ist wirklich ein Problem im Eis, okay?
Vielen Dank. Er hat dann gesagt, ja stimmt, steht in den Regeln, PDF aufgemacht irgendwie, Adobe Update, Command F, Tor verschoben. Ich weiß, Tor verschoben ist wirklich ein Problem beim Eiswaffe, aber wenn du es halt verursacht, so ein Tor zu feiern, dann ist doch bestimmt blaue Karte oder so. Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich weiß gar nicht, was ist da, kriegst du dann so ein Kalippo oder so, ich weiß gar nicht, ob dann alles so eisthematisch ist oder so. Statt einer gelben Karte hält er so ein Kalippo oder so. Oder zwei Kalippos, ein Bum-Bum, ne? Okay. Wow. Aber so mag ich Sport. Gesamte Karrieren innerhalb von zehn Minuten in einer Dekade zusammengefügt. Das finde ich immer gut. Okay, und das heißt, du kommst Compilations an. Ja, und jetzt gibt es ja so ganz viele tolle Jahrzehnte-Compilations, natürlich die besten Filme des Jahrzehnts, eben die grössten Ausrutscher, die grössten Ups-Momente des Jahrzehnts und so, die schaue ich immer gerne an. Da ist immer ganz viel dabei, so das Jahrzehnt kannst du nochmal rüber passieren lassen. Was war so ein Ups-Moment, an den du dich gerne erinnerst? Weil Ups-Moment klingt nicht so, als ob man davon eine Population braucht. Ups-Moment ist so, klingt egal. Ja, es stimmt schon ein bisschen, am liebsten mag ich eigentlich immer die Golfer, weil du denkst, okay, was kann jetzt hier alles passieren, aber am Ende kommt dann irgendwie so ein Krokodil und frisst den Ball oder so. Tatsächlich, die unerwartesten, spannendsten Dinge passieren beim Golfen, wo man ja sagt, kein Gegner kann darauf einwirken, es gibt auch keinen, in dem Sinne des Schiedsrichters, alles nicht so dramatisch, aber dann wird es dann sehr dramatisch, weil es dann in Florida halt einfach sehr viele Krokodile gibt. Ja, total. Es kommt dann einfach so ein Vogel und nimmt diesen Ball mit und fliegt den ins Nest und versucht, ihn auszubrüten irgendwie so. Und auch die Schiedsrichter so, okay, jetzt müssen wir, jetzt machen wir folgendes, müssen dann irgendwas on the fly machen. Noch besser fände ich, wenn der Vogel das ins Loch fliegt und dann so ein Vogelschiedsrichter sich sehr freut und so ein Vogelpublikum am Rand jubelt oder so. Und man sagt ganz kurz Moment und die immer sauer sind, wenn die Menschen deren Bälle wegschlagen. Die haben ein komplett eigenes Spiel, ich glaube sowas gibt es auch in der Richtung. Haben Tiere Sportarten eigentlich oder gibt es da Spieltiere manchmal auch Spiele? Naja, das ist alles sehr kampfendig, also wenn man sagt, der Hund will spielen, heisst es, er will dich töten, kann es aber noch nicht, weil im spielerischen Sinne, ja, im spielerischen, ironisch gemeint, er will dich ironisch töten und es ist manchmal so ein bisschen schwer auseinanderzuhalten, aber an sich, ja stimmt schon, also so Löwenbabys sieht man ja häufig, wie die da, Löwenbabys, Löwenbabys, ach, sorry, wir können auch das gleiche, wir können auch das gleiche, wir können auch versuchen mit Möwen zu machen, aber Möwenbabys sieht man ja auch manchmal, wie sie sich dann so käppeln und so. Das ist deren Spiel.
Ja. Oder? Ist schon so ein bisschen, aber es ist natürlich auch die Frage, wie man so als Mensch damit umgeht, wenn so ein Tier spielen will.
Man denkt sich so, du hast keine Chance, gegen mich solche zu tun, als würdest du gewinnen. Gerade wie so bei so einem Kleinkind, wo man dann das Armdrücken verliert,
aber dann so ein Kätzchen und dann so, au, Hilfe. Vor allem bei Hunden ist es auch oft schwer, weil Hunde nicht checken, dass es irgendwann auch keinen Spaß mehr macht, das Spiel. Bei Hunde sind das ja gerade im Schnitt und dann hat ein Cutter einen Hund mitgebracht den ganzen Tag und dann fand der Hund das ganz toll, dass man sein Spielzeug die ganze Zeit nimmt, wegwirft, der Klassiker, der Hund bringt es dann wieder. Aber nach Wurf 18 denkt man auch, warte, hier muss es mal irgendwas passieren. Ich hab keinen Spaß mehr, seit Wurf 2 schon nicht. Der Hund ist immer noch ganz aufgeregt und wedelt ganz aufgeregt mit dem Schwanz und so. Aber der Hund hat kein Gefühl dafür, dass es jetzt keinen Spaß mehr macht. Vor allem der Hund denkt wahrscheinlich dasselbe, so einfach, mein Gott, jetzt hab ich ihn 18 mal geholt. Jetzt wirft er schon aus Höf Wie viel will er denn noch machen, ey? Er bringt's nur aus Höflichkeit wieder. Er hat auch schon keine Lust mehr. Ja. Aber soll ich machen, den willst du nur weg. Er will es doch haben. Ja. Aber ich will nach Hause. Wer spielt hier mit wem? Was wollen Hunde eigentlich? Feierabend machen? Auch dann eine andere Kollegin, die haben gerade sehr viele Hunde in der Firma, eine andere Kollegin hat einen blinden Hund, aber so einen ganz alten Flattritten.
Oh mein, einen blinden Hund oder einen blinden Hund?
Nein, nein, nein, sie ist sozusagen der blinden Mensch für den Hund, weil der Hund kann nicht sehen.
Ach so, blinden Mensch sozusagen, ja.
Und der läuft halt immer durch den Raum mit so zittrigen Beinen, weil er auch schon sehr alt ist und das ist so ein weirder Hund, die haben so ein AT-ST eigentlich, so ganz grosse, AT-AT, so ein grosser, Wein ist auch so grau eigentlich weil ich will ihm ein bisschen mal so einen Hut und so Kanonen dran machen, aber er läuft dann so rum, läuft auch genau wie die, so unbeholfen und er sieht halt nichts und deswegen versucht er alles zu erriechen, aber du kannst ja keine Tür riechen, wenn sie näher kommen, und deswegen läuft er dann immer gegen Türen und weist dann aber an irgendeinem Punkt, ah ist die Tür, merkt sich dann auch relativ so die Ausmasse des Raums, er geht erstmal immer so in den ab, dreht dann ab und geht dann, bis er mit der Nase irgendwo anstösst und so und da denke ich mir auch, was denkt dieser Hund, also was glaubt er, wovon träumt er zum Beispiel nachts, was sieht er in seinem inneren Auge, was denkt er, was passiert, wie er diese Welt war, ich habe gar keinen Bezug zu diesem Tier. Ja, vor allem, der freut sich dann eigentlich immer nur direkt auf den nächsten Moment, wo er nicht direkt stirbt einfach so. Also ich meine so, dass er aus Situationen fliehen will, die ihm Angst machen, klar, aber so dann dieses, was will ich letztens eigentlich. Ja, oder er will gerade einfach in den Tod laufen und hofft die ganze Zeit, dass es keine Tür kommt, sondern einfach Lava oder so, weil er einfach selber nicht mehr leben will. Weiß man ja auch nicht. Aber irgendwann wird er einfach mal in Vulkan fallen und sterben und wird sich gar nicht merken, warum, wird gar nicht wissen, was er falsch gemacht hat. Das ist eigentlich traurig. Ja, oder ist er schön für ihn, du weißt ja nicht. Ist ja auch eine Erlösung. Niemand weiss, das ist ja auch so ein bisschen das Argument, das ich oft gehört habe, zum Thema Massentierhaltung, wo es dann heisst, ja, aber je schlechter es denen geht, desto mehr freuen die sich, wenn die geschlachtet werden.
Da denkst du, da kann ich jetzt nichts dagegen sagen. Das ist reine Logik, also hundertprozentig von vorne. Wir Allesesser, wir haben sehr viele Argumente euch Veganer gegenüber mittlerweile, wie du merkst, und wir haben noch mehr, da wo die herkommen. Ich glaube, in der Massentierhaltung ist Schlachtung auch freiwillig. Die sagen so, so, wer hat Lust heute, ich, ich, ich, ich, oh, bin ich lecker, und dann zack, es kann schon sein, kein Mensch weiß, wie Tiere denken, vielleicht können Tiere irgendwann sprechen und sagen, oh, ey, alter, als sie uns da dieses Zeug in den Hals gestopft hat, oh, war das geil, warum hat er damit aufgehört, warum hat er damit aufgehört, wie es so eine Doku gab über Tiere, Massentierhaltung und so weiter, und dann waren da Kühe so ganz furchtbar und eng aneinandergepfercht und die haben halt geweint, sie hatten Tränen und so, aber dann hat die Doku gesagt, und diese Doku war super parteiisch und gesagt, auf gar keinen Fall Massentierhaltung unterstützen, man sollte weniger Fleisch essen und so, aber diese Kühe weinen gerade nicht wirklich, die haben einfach nur Staub, es ist sehr trocken, deswegen haben die alle Staub in den Augen, weil Tiere weinen, also die Küheinen nicht und so. Man denkt die ganze Zeit, ja, warum macht ihr dann diesen Punkt, also das ist so weird, man will zum einen faktisch korrekt sein, auf der anderen Seite zeigt man aber diese weinende Kühe, weil man denkt, oh nein, dann ist es so viel emotional stärker, dass man diese weinenden Kühe zeigt, aber da muss man erwähnen, dass sie nicht weinen aufgrund von Emotionen, weil Tiere gar nicht weinen. Das ist wirklich schwierig. Einfach wenn die Bilder nicht zu viel hergeben, als dass man... Ja! Gebt mir mal so Bilder von traurigen Tieren. Zu traurig. Zu traurig? Das ist... Ne, zu ihre weinen. Was macht ihr da? Gegoogelt Selbstmord? Nein, nein, nein, das ist zu krass weniger traurig. Die Befleckung der Kuh ist aus Versehen Hilfe. Einfach kurz. Ne, das ist nee, das ist auch unrealistisch. Das haben wir da reingeschafft oder sowas. So dieses Stockfotofotografen-Problem, was wenn ein Bild zu gut passt. Achso, ich dachte, wenn Bilder immer ein Wasserzeichen haben. Das natürlich auch. Ich denke, Fotografen von Getty, oh mein Gott. Ja, stimmt, genau, wenn die Kuh ein Wasserzeichen hat und der Fotograf völlig verzweifelt ist. Fuck, wie mache ich das? Das stimmt schon. Man weiss nicht, wann Tiere sterben wollen, man weiss nicht, was ihnen vor sich geht. Ich war über Weihnachten zu Hause und mein Weihnachten bestand vor allem aus einem Notartermin, weil ich war wieder in meiner Heimat, habe meine Mutter besucht und sie hat die Gunst der Stunde, wo ich mir wieder zu Hause war, genutzt, um mich zum Notar zu schleppen, um so eine Patientenverfügung endlich mal in den Staat zu bekommen. Ich bin ja beim Notar und ich habe das wirklich ein bisschen unterschätzt, ich habe das vorher auch alles geschickt und es sind ja schon auch wichtige Dokumente. Und da dachte ich irgendwann so, du hast das Leben echt nicht mehr im Griff, weil ich habe das so überflogen und so und Und dann hat der Notar mich dann aber angeguckt, als ich da saß und hat gesagt, sie will das ja gelesen.
Und ich habe natürlich gefolgt gelogen und gesagt, ja, ja, auf jeden Fall, das ist ja so ein Testament, das ist ja schon auch wichtig, dass man das jetzt gelesen hat. In meinem Kopf dachte ich mir, oh mein Gott, das ist wirklich so eine krasse Kacklüge gerade. Was solltest du gelesen haben, wie dumm du bist? Ja, und dann war es wirklich anderthalb Stunden Verlesen des letzten Willens meiner Mutter und eine Patientenverfügung dahinter noch dran. Also so will ich dann auch noch die Zugabe auch noch hinten dran. Und das war mein Weihnachten, einfach zwei Stunden beim Notar. Und dann hat er mich, glaube ich, auch ein bisschen für dumm gehalten, hat dann immer nach jedem Absatz mir sehr anschaulich erklärt, was das bedeutet. Und dann war es zum Beispiel, ja, das, und dann denke ich mir, was ein geiler Beruf eigentlich, der Beruf des Notars ist, weil er dann sehr, sehr ausschweifend immer erklärt hat, was das bedeutet, zum Beispiel, ja, dass zum Beispiel, wenn ihre Mutter vom Auto überfahren wird, aber am Unfallort dann noch nicht so sehr verwundet ist, dass sie sich noch artikulieren kann. Er liegt zum Beispiel auf dem Boden und kann noch sagen, nee, Stefan bekommt doch nichts mehr und ich so, oh mein Gott, es ist ja 25. Dezember, warum ist die überhaupt geöffnet? Und das war mein Weihnachten und dann ist es wirklich Wahnsinn, wie er immer angefangen hat, neue Beispiele zu finden. Und ich dachte mir irgendwann so, das musst du mitschreiben, das ist kein Drehbuchauter der Welt, es könnte auf so viele furchtbare Szenarien kommen und so. Wahrscheinlich, ja, Notar-Splatter-Filmregisseur oder so. Das wäre eigentlich geil, aber es wird immer grauenvoller. Aber hat deine Mutter dann auch immer so gesagt, so, ja, aber das werde ich ja nicht machen. Also wenn ich beide Beine verliere und sterbe auf dem Boden liegt, dann werde ich ja nicht auch noch sagen, ich habe Schluchzen, Tränen lauten drunter, Mama, nein! Aber wie ausschweifend kann das sein? Kann er sagen, wenn Stefan mich getötet hat, dann kriegt er nichts mehr, einfach so, wenn man nicht weiss, wer das Auto gefahren hat. Man will sich ja absichern. Sie hat sich ja auch abgesichert. Sie hat sich ja auch abgesichert. Da ist so eine Klausel, so von wegen, wenn sie mir irgendwann nicht mehr vertraut ist, ist es auch ganz einfach ganz schnell wieder weg, das Geld. Aber gibt es nicht eine Klausel, wenn mich der, der das Geld... Auch so, wenn ich privat insolvent gehe, solche Sachen sind da auch drin.
Und ich muss sagen, Leute, also, darauf wollen wir jetzt mal nicht ausgehen. Aber kann man nicht schreiben, so wenn die Person die Erbenwürde mich getötet hat, dann soll sie nichts kriegen. Ah, geil. So dass man bei, es gibt ja viele Morde natürlich aus Erberschleichung, wissen wir ja beide. und deswegen also aus Büchern, aus Gifs, die wir uns angeschaut haben.
Und deswegen, glaube ich, müssen Sie diese Klausel eigentlich immer mindestens einmal heilen.
Ja, wo ich auch so sagen würde, wenn er drin gestanden hätte, wenn mich mein Sohn umgebracht hat, kriegt er gar nichts ab, Leute. Nichts auch, nicht so schlecht, ist dann rechtsgehörig, ich weiß nicht, kriegt dann gar nichts ab, wo ich dann auch dachte, der hätte mich auch umgedreht und gesagt, ja, ja, nice, nice, Mama.
Gut, das ist gut abgesichert.
Ja, ist schwierig, hast du schon Ideen für dein Testament, irgendwas überlegt? Wer kriegt einen ATS-D?
Ja, ich glaube, so ein paar Sachen habe ich geklärt, also gerade weil, das war damals, wo meine grösste, das war schon ein bisschen länger her, mein grösster Wert war im Bandkeller, so ein paar Lautsprecherboxen, mein Bassverstärker und so. Das war mein Grösster, als Kind hat man ja nicht, macht ja nicht viel. Und meine grössten Wertanlagen waren halt wahrscheinlich mein Bass, mein E-Bass und der Verstärker und so. Und das habe ich damals, hätte ich einem Kumpel vermacht, einem Bandkollegen, der hätte das alles bekommen tatsächlich, das habe ich da reingeschrieben.
Und das hast du auch, also du hast ein Testament geschrieben, wo das drinsteht.
Ja, und das ist, glaube ich, wenn ich recht nachdenke, immer noch Aufstand. Das heißt, alle anderen Sachen werden wahrscheinlich irgendwie für einen guten Zweck oder gehen an den Staat oder werden verscherbelt oder irgendwie versteigert, so zwangsvollsteigungsmäßig. Ja.
Und diesen Bassbox kriegt der Kumpel von mir immer noch, der sich auch denkt, alter,
willst du mich verarschen, so 150 Euro wert krieg ich. Naja. Nee, habe ich noch nicht, ich müsste mal drüber nachdenken. Denk mal drüber nach. Ich müsste mal auch drüber nachdenken, ich glaube, wie gesagt, mein grösster Wert ist mein Kleingeldeimer, wo, glaube ich, mittlerweile wirklich mehrere tausend Euro einfach drin sind an Kleingeld. Ja, und den will man natürlich aber auch nicht jemandem vermachen, wenn man einfach an der Notar kommt und, dann so angeschleppt wird, einfach so hier, bitte ist ihr Erbe und dann kannst du das alles selber einzahlen oder so, das ist dann auch nicht so gut. Ja, vor allem, das zahlt derjenige dann auch nicht ein, sondern er hat dann das zuhause, das kommt dann zu seinem anderen Kleingeld zuhause, wie alle von uns Kleingeld zuhause haben und nicht damit zur Bank gehen. Ich habe neulich, bei mir hat es so eine gewisse Grenze auch überschritten, dank meines neuen Portemonnaies. Jesus, jeden Tag. Ich meine, ihr erlebt das einmal in der Woche, ich erlebe es jeden Tag, dass Stefan über sein Portemonnaie redet. Also, mein neues Portemonnaie hat ja den Magneten, wir erinnern uns. Und nicht nur war ich neulich in einem Hotel, wo das andere noch Kartengebot gemacht hat, nein, es wird auch das so, das hat ja auch kein Münzfach, weil ich da mich ja mit meinem alten Portemonnaie schon seelisch von getrennt habe, habe ich immer noch kein Münzfach und deswegen sammelt sich bei mir zu Hause jetzt auch aber grosses Münzgeld, also wirklich so zwei Euro Stücke, das schafften sich auch schon mittlerweile, wo ich mir jeden Morgen so Lunchgeld mässig noch was einstecke, man weiss ja nie, was passiert, kann man da mal gebrauchen,
aber im grossen und ganzen will es nicht weniger, weil man halt auch viel mit Schein bezahlt und dann halt was zurückkommt. Und deswegen hat es so eine Grenze überschritten, wo ich sage, das ist nicht mehr okay und deswegen habe ich das Problem aktiv beheben wollen, habe mich bei der Sparkasse informiert, wie man das denn jetzt in den Griff bekommt und man muss es einrollen. Nein Nein, da gibt es diesen Schlemmerautomaten, der das alles einf... den man das geben kann. Doch, doch, doch. Ich verstehe genau, was du meinst, so Schlemmerautomaten, aber das gibt es nicht mehr. Der snackt das weg? Der snackt das weg? Nein, es gibt keinen Wecksnackerautomaten. Klar! Es gibt bei der Sparkasse zumindest keinen Wecksnacker mehr. Was? Der steht da nicht mehr. Nein, da gibt es diese Kontoauszuggedöns, die auch verboten gehören. Ganz kurz, weil da Papiere rauskommen, das ist völlig unnötig. Man kann sich einfach Onlinebanking mässig besorgen. Werde doch aller Meinung, oder wie ich auch. Nein, wir lieben diese Automaten, Stefan. Wir lieben sie. Ich finde, man sollte die wegschaffen und dafür mehr diese Wcksnacker hinstellen. Weil das ist doch, Kleingeld haben wir doch alle. Lieber von uns brauchen wir Kontoauszüge. Da hat wohl niemandem Kontoauszüge besorgt. So! Nein, stopp! Stopp! Nein! Einer ruft! Keine Mutter! Ich muss mir das Wochenlang anhören mit seinem Scheiss, dann gründet er wieder eine Schlemmerpartei und macht dann immer hier die ganze Klamm und Bullshit. So, wir gründen nämlich jetzt die zwei Leute, die in den Landstaben, wir gründen doch sind doch eine Runde Partei. Und dann schreibt er in sein Scheiss Testament, dass ich die Partei erbe und dann bin ich vollkommen. Dann muss ich mit dem Scheiss rumschlagen. Sehr viele Aufgaben. Krieg eine eigene Abgeordneten und dann sitzt er da rum und denkst, was soll das sein? Bei meinem Testament sollen so viele böse Twists versteckt sein. Ja. So, ihr erbt alle was, alle die ich kenne, aber alle haben dann so blöde Organaufgaben. Ja, ja, ja.
Aber auch einfach so, wenn ich sterbe, soll jeder meiner Freunde einen Euro kriegen.
Ausser Stefan, der kriegt 50 Cent.
Und dann einfach so stirbt und alle so, what, what, was ist das?
Aber lustig.
Wie viel habt ihr gekriegt, einen Euro?
Ne, auch mal.
Ich hab auch einen Euro.
Ich hab auch mal.
Ich hab zwei Euro bekommen, aber einspende ich. Aber den anderen behalte ich als Andenken und so. Ja, oder auch unsere Leute, mit denen man gar keinen Kontakt mehr hat. Ich würde sowas reinschreiben wie, jeder, mit dem ich auf Facebook befreundet bin, kriegt eines meiner T-Shirts oder so. Und dann muss irgendein Notar so, ah, Jesus, ah, Annabelle aus der vierten Klasse, irgendwie kriegt dann so ein T-Shirt und Annabelle fragt sich, what the fuck, was ist das, was ist damit los? Und jedes, genau, jeder kriegt ein Shirt. So und bei Primzahlen, also die erste, jede Primzahl verschickter Shirts kriegt zwei. Ja genau, das finde ich gut, das finde ich richtig gut. Einfach grösstmögliche Verwirrung sehen oder einfach sowas. Ich möchte, dass ich begraben werde mit einem riesigen Löffel in der rechten Hand. Ja genau, weil du willst ... Also Sekunde, Moment, was ... Welcher, war er religiös eigentlich, war er spirituell?
Hatte das, es gibt ein Video, das ging natürlich viral, wo ein Mann begraben wurde und dann hat er wohl hinterlassen in seinem letzten Willen, dass plötzlich so eine Rede losgehen soll, die er vorher aufgenommen hat. So, knock, knock, knock, ha, ich bin's und alle verwandten, what?
Und dann hat halt der Pfarrer, wurde dann mit der Aufgabe getraut, hinterm Grabstein dann so einen Lautsprecher anzumachen, um diese Ansage loszugehen. Und dann hat er so einen Dad-Joke gemacht und alle Verwandten haben halt so herzlich gelacht, aber man denkt sich doch, also ich würde immer so denken, Papa, muss das jetzt sein?
Ja, dann kommt es, die Idee ist ja ganz lustig und so, aber dann ist das, windet es doll oder so, oder es regnet und dann wird die Lautsprecher nass und dann krüsselt diese Aufnahme so oder man hört die nicht richtig. Ja genau, zu laut, zu leise. Das geht dann nachher von vorne los, der Pfarrer macht bei Track 1 an das erste Dancing Queen von Abba und so. Es kann ja so viel schief gehen. Ja, furchtbar. Der Gag ist ja ganz nett, aber was da alles passieren kann. Ich glaube, das ist doch das Schlimmste am Pfarrerjob dann irgendwie. Jemand ist gestorben? Ja, okay, schade, aber okay. Okay, gibt man das Testament. Bitte kein Bullshit, denke ich. Bitte kein Bullshit, bitte kein Bullshit. Der Pfarrer soll einen roten Hut tragen. Mein Gott, Fick, ja, okay, kann er schlecht Nein sagen. Er geht das auf den Schrank und macht ihn auf und da sind so Lametta und ganz viele bunte Hüte drin. Er schnappt sich den roten und denkt, wir beide wieder, setz ihn auf und geht raus, raus zur Beerdigung. Ach ja, eigentlich, ich meine, bist du, bist du, hast du mit dem Leben abgeschlossen, also bist du bereit für den, also im Sinne von, bist du, bist du dem, hast du. Ja, nee, ich bin jetzt 25, da kann man schon mit dem Leben abschliessen, habe ich so das Gefühl. Ich kann mich auch erinnern, dass ich als Kind sehr viel Todesangst hatte. Ja, das stimmt, das habe ich gar nicht mehr. Das denke ich mir auch manchmal. Ich war gestern, vorgestern bin ich geflogen, weiß ich, soll man nicht mehr, ging nicht anders, sah sich, dass ich da oben... Wohin bist du geflogen, wo es nicht anders hinging? Ich glaube, jeder, der Stefan auf Instagram folgt, weiss, wo Stefan hingeflogen ist.
Hä? Ja. Weiss, Köln oder was? Das willst du jetzt. Magst du? Der Schatten des Ständers ist in deinem Schritt. Das lenkt mich ab. Sorry. Ganz kurz. Sorry. Also ich kann überall hingehen, außer hier. Ja. Es sei denn, wenn es im Testament steht. Wenn jemand so sagt, ja, ich muss euch was Ernstes sagen, aber die ganze Zeit so einen schattlichen Schritt hat, so die ganze Zeit. Das wiegt wie so ein Pfeil, das wiegt dann wie so ein ... Ich habe seit Jahren ein ernstes Alkoholproblem und ich habe kein Geld mehr und die ganze Zeit ab. Ich bin geflogen und dann gab es Turbulenzen und ich dachte mir dann irgendwann auch so, wie cool, bei einem Flugzeugabschluss zu sterben. Es macht sich immer auf einem Wikipedia-Eintrag meistens richtig gut. Ja, macht sich richtig gut. Ist richtig gut. Oder nicht? Ja, eigentlich schon. Vor allem ist es, es, es, es, es, es, es, man gibt immer, eigentlich will er auf eine Art sterben, wo man immer denkt, vielleicht lebt er noch. So, wo man immer denkt, so vielleicht kommt er irgendwann nochmal. Ja, weil es da diese geilen Gerüchte gibt, wie vielleicht hat er das nur gefakt, ja genau, eigentlich liebt er es in Argentinien, als Nazi. Genau, vielleicht, um ein paar Twists reinzuhauen. Wenn du ein paar Wochen mit den alten Nazis in Argentinien lebst, dann wirst du zwangsläufig auch Nazi. Du kannst nicht auf dem Mond mit Göring und Hitler leben und irgendwann einfach sagen, nee, also ich wähle SPD schon noch. Also das ist schon noch mein Plan bei der nächsten Wahl, aber ansonsten ist es eine coole Uniform, ein cooles Auto, kann man nichts anders sagen. Glaubst du, Nazis leben auf dem Mond? Ja, bestimmt, bestimmt. Auf der anderen Seite denke ich mir so, wenn Hitler auf dem Mond geflohen wäre und dann hätten die Nürnberger Prozesse stattgefunden, wo ja alle gesagt haben, dass er schuld war. Wäre er zurückgekommen und hätte gesagt, naja, sag mal jetzt eine Sekunde ganz kurz. Also ich hatte ein paar Ideen am Anfang, aber dann habe ich auch viel Freiheiten gelassen in der, so ne, also das ist nur mal am Rande.. Der hätte irgendwas gemacht, glaube ich, deswegen glaube ich da nicht dran. Vor einigen Jahrzehnten wurde ein Meteorit auf der Erde gefunden und hat man jetzt erkannt, dass da Materialien drin sind, die schon älter sind als die Erde und die Sonne. Weil die Sonne ist ungefähr so viereinhalb Milliarden Jahre alt und auf diesem, nee, nein, Stefan, wenn du sowas sagst, musst du einfach weiterreden. Alle haben sich gedacht ... Aber denk doch mal an die Mails, denk doch mal an die Mails, und dann stimmt's wieder nicht, dann schreibt uns Anna Frebel. Leute, ihr habt ja nichts gelernt auf dem Gespräch mit uns. Nein, ich glaube, in viereinhalb Jahren, Jahre macht es ungefähr Sinn. Ja, passt schon. Aber dieses Sternenstaubmaterial mit Meteoriten
war sieben Milliarden
auf dieser Skala, Milliarden
Lichtjahre. Ja, ja, ja.
Und das fand ich... Älter.
Älter. Und das war sehr beeindruckend,
fand ich. Man findet sich auf der Erde etwas, was älter
ist als die Sonne. Das ist ja fantastisch.
Und da hat man sogar Sachen gefunden,
die gar nicht existieren auf der Erde.
Sogar Minerale, die gar nicht existieren. Und aber auch so Aminosäuren und so ein Bullshit, was es wohl braucht, um Leben, also als Grundlage fürs Leben dienlich ist. Gott sei Dank, habe ich diesen Satz beenden können. Und dann, das gibt es auf der Erde teilweise dann auch gar nicht, solche Sachen. Das fand ich ganz beeindruckend, weil da draußen ist ja was. Vielleicht nicht auf dem Mond, vielleicht nicht die Nazis auf dem Mond, aber da draußen ist was, Florentin. Da glaube ich fest dran. Sprachbarriere ist schon ein Problem, glaube ich auch. Ja. Ich glaube nicht, dass wir die gleiche Sprache sprechen. Naja, die kennen halt, alles was sie von der Erde kennen, sind die Black Eyed Peas und ansonsten halt nicht viel. Das heißt, die gesamten Vokabular der Black Eyed Peas haben die schon mal drin, haben die schon mal drauf, aber mehr halt auch nicht. Wie traurig die sein werden, wie viel Let's Get It Started, von I Got a Feeling und so. Let's Get It Started. Let's Get It Started, I Got a Feeling, wo ist Fergie? Und dann wollen die unbedingt mit Fergie sprechen, weil die irgendwie die Präsidentin des Universums oder so, des Universums. und finden die die nicht, weil die schon gestorben sind, weil die wahrscheinlich erst in den Lichtjahren ankommen. Fergie wird niemals sterben, Stefan, das wissen wir beide. Aber ich hatte letztens eine sehr schreckliche Nacht und hatte auch sehr oft an den Tod gedacht, ehrlich gesagt, weil ich hatte sehr intensive Rückenschmerzen und konnte deswegen die komplette Nacht nicht schlafen. Ist nichts, woran man stirbt. Ist nichts, woran man stirbt, aber weiss man nicht. Ich war offen, ich war offen für alles in der Nacht. Aber man hat auch meistens total dusselige Gedanken, ne? Ja, man hat super dusselige Gedanken, vor allem, du hast halt fucking Rückenschmerzen nachts, drei Uhr nachts und fängst dann wirklich halb vier Uhr nachts an, Yoga zu machen. Und ich habe wirklich meinen Rücken so lachen gehört, so, ha ha, das ist ein bisschen schwer, mein Freund. Das ist jetzt wirklich, jetzt, wo du kurz davor bist, dass ich mir so vorgestellt, dass ich einfach so in der Mitte auseinanderbreche. Einfach wie so ein KitKat, einfach so krack und dann hänge ich halt einfach so rum und dann ist einfach kein Rückhalt mehr. Aber du weisst ja mittlerweile auch, die Wege zum Krankenhaus, hast du ja schon ein paar Mal zurückgelegt. Ja, das stimmt, das war jetzt zwar in einer anderen Stadt, aber ich habe es schon zurückgelegt,
aber dann fängst du wirklich um halb vier und nachts mit irgendwelchen Dehnübungen an und ich kam mir noch nie so erbärmlich vor, wie in der Situation.
Nachts überdenkt man auch Dinge generell anders, alles wirkt ein bisschen anders, so perfide, weil nachts hast du nichts zu tun, du hast nachts im Bett zu liegen, das ist ja auch das seltsame, dann denkt man immer, warum macht man das gerade und so, man stellt sich ganz andere Fragen auf. Ich glaube, man ist auch nachts schlecht gelaunt, das ist auch so hormonell bedingt.
Ich glaube, man hat nachts, das habe ich mir immer gelesen, wenn man nachts aufwacht, ist man dann meistens grummelig und denkt über den nächsten Tag nach und schläft dann wütend durch so eine Faust wieder ein, weil man ist dann ein bisschen müde, aber auch sauer.
Und das ist eine schlechte Kombination, das ist ja immer so, du liegst dann wach und hast dich dich dafür, dass du nicht einschlafen kannst, und der Hass hält dich wach. Hass dich nicht wach. Weil dann kannst du weiter hassen und weiter hassen. Das funktioniert nicht. Ne, das stimmt. Aber ich glaube, ja, so die Frage, was zuerst da war, dann die schlechte Laune hormonell oder der Wut darüber, dass man nicht einschlafen kann einfach. Und das schüttert dann Hormone aus. Weiß ich nicht. Können ein Schlafwissenschaftler erklären. Wir sind nur hier Fragen zu stellen. Ich glaube, die Schlafwissenschaftler sind nicht mehr wach um die Uhrzeit. Sie können es einfach nicht erwarten, wenn du den ganzen Tag nur über Schlaf redest, sondern so gegen 17.30 Uhr so. Aber genau, neulich nachts wurde ich wach von meiner Heizung, meiner Gastherme. Die hat dann angefangen, so wieder Geräusche zu machen. Und ich bin handwerklich nullbasiert, gar nichts, ich krieg nichts hin. Also Glühbirne wechseln, das ist das höchste Gefühl. Und nachts war dann, das Geräusch kannte ich aber, und ich hab das Geräusch gehört, meine Gastherme, bin wacht davon geworden und dachte, ich wusste genau, was zu tun war. Ich war nur zu faul, es halt in der Nacht zu machen, weil dieses Gefäss, ich weiss auch nicht, wie es heisst, das einzige, was ich daran reparieren kann,
ich weiss nicht mehr genau, wie es heisst, aber es ist, da ist dann so, da ist Wasser drin in der Gastherme und es ist leer. So, und dann muss ich es auffüllen, dann ist der Wasserdruck zu niedrig und dann weiss, ich habe mich auch mit Schlauch dafür gekauft und so und habe eine Zange, die da ist und dann kann ich es aufmachen, kann Wasserhahn anstecken, den Schlauch dran, dann mache ich das Gefäß wieder voll und dann kann ich schlafen gehen. Aber diese dumme, dusselige Aufgabe hat sich in der Nacht so falsch angefühlt, weil das hat in der Nacht nichts zu tun. Du hast in der Nacht das zu schlafen. Ja, es ist wirklich so, aber es ist auch ein wahnsinniges Freiheitsgefühl, wenn du in der Nacht aufwachst, wo du denkst, das ist jetzt eigentlich Bonuszeit. Und wenn ich mir jetzt irgendwie ein schönes Rührei mache oder so. Das ist der grösste Quart. Das ist ein Bonusei. Das zählt nicht. Das zählt nicht. Das ist aber auch ein Bonus-Ei.
Ja, das ist ein Bonus-Ei.
Ja, das ist einfach Bonus-Ei. Jedes Snickers, was ich mir jetzt reinhaue, schlägt nicht aufs Gewicht.
Ja, es ist...
Bonus Snickers.
Es ist alles oben drauf.
Bonus Stunde. Ich kann jetzt machen, was ich will. Keine Zeit geht verloren.
Ja.
Aber das ist genau das hier die Illusion. Deswegen hat man als Kind ja auch immer so gerne bei Sleepovers,
Sleepovers hat man ja gerne gesprochen oder hat gezockt oder sowas, weil man dachte, wie geil, man hat irgendwie das wie so ein Spiel in so einen extra Raum zu gehen, wo man so eine Parallelwelt entdeckt und sowas, aber am nächsten Tag merkt man, man ist sehr, sehr müde und dann verschenkt man diese Bonuszeit auch wieder. Ja, aber ich finde, das ist die schönste Zeit des Tages, auch wenn man irgendwo einen Termin hat. Wir treffen uns um 17.30 Uhr und du bist um 17.20 Uhr da. Und du hast einfach so zehn Minuten für mich. Ich kann machen, was ich will, und am Ende denke ich darüber nach, dass ich bald sterben werde. Und dann komme ich einfach schon mal gut wieder in den Termin. Und man weiß einfach so, ich bin im richtigen Mindset drin. Aber das ist so die freie Zeit. Wie willst du denn gerne sterben? Du wolltest was anderes sagen. Ja, nee. Darfst du auch? Nee, weil ich hatte ganz kurz noch ein, wo du gesagt hast, du kennst das Geräusch, aber du weisst nicht genau woher. Ich hatte genau das gleiche Phänomen, wo man sich so denkt, so okay, der Programmierer der Realität war wieder faul. Hier wurde was gegen Copy-Paste. Und zwar, ja, ist es nicht das coolste Hobby der Welt, aber ich habe ein neues Hobby, ja, das ist Tee, ich trinke ganz gern Tee, ich habe mir ein Teebuch gekauft, über Tee, ja, ist jetzt nicht das coolste Hobby der Welt, aber es ist zwar so.
Das ist glaube ich das uncoolste Hobby der Welt.
So, stopp, es ist das uncoolste Hobby.
Also so vor Modellbau ist noch so vielleicht ein bisschen uncooler, so Eisenbahn.
Es ist das uncoolste Hobby, bis ich dir erzähle, welchen Tee ich heute getrunken habe.
Und zwar habe ich heute getrunken, russischen Rauchtee.
So Freunde, wenn das nicht cool ist, dann könnt ihr sofort abhauen, Freunde, weil das ist schon eine coole Sache. Und das Zeug schmeckt wie ein Lagerfeuer einfach. Du denkst dir, wie kann sowas so schmecken? Aber das Geile ist, ich habe an diesem Tee gerochen und du bist ja Tennisspieler, du hast ja mal Tennis gespielt. Ja, für Tennisspieler, weil ich das nicht so ausdrücken würde. Naja, und Tennisbälle kommen ja oft in diesen Röhren, mit diesen vier Tennisbällen in dieser Röhre drin. Und wenn man die aufmacht, dann haben die ja wie so Erdnüsschen, haben die so einen Verschluss, so einen Luftverschluss. Das stimmt, ja. Aber es riecht so gut, aber dann riecht es. Genau, und dieser Geruch, ich schwöre, ist eins zu eins, aber wirklich eins zu eins der Geruch von russischem Rauchteam. Nein, aber Moment, du hast gerade gesagt, es riecht nach Lagerfeuer. Nein, es schmeckt wie Lagerfeuer, aber es riecht wie der Inhalt von Tennisballröhren. So, so wurde er mir verkauft und ich bin mit 200 Gramm-Kollegen. Wenn du so Tee-Sommelier, Tee-Kondisseur-artig auf einer Karte, bei Weinen steht er dann immer, er hat eine feurige Note, rauchig, schmeckt nach Minze im Abgang und so weiter, würde dann bei dem Tee stehen, schmeckt nach, riecht nach Tennisröhren.
Ja, einfach so Dunlop-Vierer von 1992, war ein guter Jahrgang für die Tennisröhren.
Gut er Jahrgang, aber es ist wirklich mit der beste Geruch.
Es ist wirklich der beste Geruch und es ist so ein ganz merkwürdiger Geruch, weil vor allem, was einem ja oft nicht klar ist, man hat ja teilweise Luft um sich aus ganz anderen Bereichen der Welt. Also angenommen, du kaufst einen Tischtennisball, einen Tischtennisball, da ist ja Luft drin, aber das ist ja keine deutsche Luft, sondern das ist halt irgendwo chinesische Luft, wo der in China hergestellt wird. Eingeschlossen. Aber was, also du denkst immer nur, der Ball, der Ball, der Ball, wow, wie toll, ich habe einen Tischtennisball, ich bin der Grösste.
Aber woran man selten denkt ist, nein, in diesem Tisch, das ist ja ein Behälter für eine Luft aus einer ganz anderen Welt, ganz anders aus einem Globus.
Und manchmal mache ich so den Tischtennisball auf und atme so die, wo ich mir denke so, oh, das ist jetzt.
Und zack, irgendwie Beulenpest oder sowas, weil, aber es kann ... Weil du so eine Zeitkapsel aus dem Mittelalter aufgemacht hast. Ja, es kann gut sein, weil teilweise gibt es ja auch noch Tische. Nein, kann es nicht. Doch, aber du weißt ja nicht, wann der hergestellt wird. Der kann ja aus den 70er Jahren sein oder so. Keine Ahnung, wenn die mal Tischtennisbälle kaufen und die haben gesagt, okay, wie viele Tischtennisbälle stellen wir her, 4 Milliarden und dann stehen die halt rum die nächsten dreissig Jahre.
Die ganzen Tischtennisball-Inflation. Ja, du hast nicht nur Luft aus einem anderen Land, sondern auch aus einer anderen Zeit und das realisieren die meisten von euch nicht. Vollidiot. Ein, zwei Leute haben das vielleicht realisiert, aber der Rest so dumm einfach. Ja, dankeschön, das ist mal die Wertschätzung für fremde Luft. Es ist ein sehr spezieller Appller Applaus, mit der speziellste, der hier mal, glaube ich, in der letzten Zeit gegeben wurde. Aber es gibt ja auch manchmal Fremde Luft, so klasse. Macht das einfach mal. Die finde ich gut, die Fremde Luft. Macht das einfach mal. Jeder von euch kennt jemanden. Aber das habe ich mir auch schon mal gedacht, weil es gibt ja diese Turi-Abzocken. So, man kann sich ja auch zum Beispiel in Rom, kannst du dir Römer Luft kaufen. Das gibt es ja manchmal in so weirden Touri-Läden, wo diese I Love Läden, da gibt es ja dann diese I Love Rom, I Love Paris Läden und so. Da gibt es dann auch immer so ein bisschen so ein Regal, die in ein Tiefgelapter, wo man einfach diese Dosen findet, wo einfach nur Luft davon drin ist. Wow. Ja, das geht das. Clever. Für dich oder wie du, die dann sagen, wow, da hätte ich Römerluft, wie Wahnsinn ist das denn, vielleicht wurde das in den 70er Jahren abgefüllt, aber man kann es nicht fassen und ich stehe am Kolosseum und weise nicht und lerne was über die Geschichte und du stimmst in diesem Turiladen und kaufst dir diese scheiss Dose. Ja, aber sind wir mal ganz ehrlich, zu relativ hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit werden diese Dosen in China hergestellt, oder?
Als ob die Exilern in Rom nochmal das aufmachen und dann muss einer in Praktik dann Luft einfangen. Natürlich werden die China hergestellt. Er muss sie nicht einfangen. Verstehst du es nicht? Wie kannst du dir so viele Gedanken machen und dann denken, du musst die Luft einfangen? Wie kannst du bis hierhin gekommen sein mit dem Gespräch? Und dann wedeln. Überall in Rom ist Römer Luft. Jeder von euch hat ja bestimmt irgendeinen Bekannten, die diese potthässlichen Glaskugel-Dekorations-Bullshit haben. Ich weiß nicht genau, ob das der Fachbegriff ist, ich bin kein Architekt. Glaskugel-Dekorations-Bullshit. Aber diese Glaskugeln, die halt dann an der Wand hängen vor dem dem Fenster, und du denkst dir, das wird ein Feuer auslösen, früher oder später, aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Und so, und dann denk ich mir auch so, irgendwann mal, schlag die kaputt und atme das ein, einfach, weil da ist irgendeine fremde Luft drin, das ist wirklich gut. Aber denkst du das ja auch bei Wasser, also denkst du das ja auch bei diesen Kugeln, diesen Schneekugeln, das ist das Wort, glaube ich.
Niemand weiß, was da drin ist, ne?
Doch, Wasser, oder nicht?
Nein, da ist kein Wasser drin.
Hä?
Da ist bestimmt, Wasser würde doch irgendwie schimmeln oder so, oder nicht, kann es nicht so gehen.
Nee, da ist ja sonst nichts drin.
Keine Ahnung, ich habe keine Ahnung von gar nichts, aber ich glaube, es ist kein Wasser.
Ich behaupte mal ganz klar, dass es destellte Wasser.
Machen wir heute mal einen Test.
Heute?
So eine Kugel einfach, wir machen sie kaputt und atmen ein, was auch immer da rauskommt. Und echsen es. Ja, genau wie ich, ich würde mal echt gerne mal den Inhalt von Lavalampen probieren. Ja, es sieht schmackhaft aus, es sieht wirklich schmackhaft aus. Es sieht giftiger aus als Arsen. Ja, ja, ja. Nee, ich hatte auch mal eine Lavalampe und dann hatte ich die Katze, die war sehr jung, und dann hat die immer so die Lavakugeln gejagt und ich dachte mir so, I feel you, ich will die auch haben, wollen die alle haben, aber die sind drin in Lava, so, was soll ich machen? Aber das ist ja so ein bisschen so wie Eigelb dann auch, glaube ich, irgendwie so. Es gefärbt ist Eigelb. Ja. Das stimmt. Du willst es einfach haben. Aber in Schneebällen ist es, glaube ich, einfach Wasser und dann so ein Bällchen. Und dann kannst du es schütteln und dann gehen die Bällchen nach oben, und dann kannst du es hinstellen und fliegen die Bällchen nach unten. Langsamer, weil natürlich die Dichte noch Wasser höher ist als die von Luft. Vielen Dank. Ja, völlig richtig. Sehr gut. Stefan Tietze, meine Damen und Herren. Sehr gut. Und daran merkt man auch, wie tief dieses Projekt gesunken ist. Ich glaube wirklich... Ich glaube aber wirklich im Ernst, wenn wir uns jetzt hier auf die Bühne stellen würden und sagen, okay Freunde, wir fangen um 20. an und wir sagen alles, was wir wissen, wären wir jetzt fertig. Wir kämen, glaube ich, durch an so einem Arm. Es sind wirklich einfach mal so, was weiß ich über Wasser, Wasser ist nass. Und dann fängst du an und ich glaube, man käme irgendwann relativ weil das ist irgendwann durch. Fangen wir mal an mit, wie funktioniert dein Mikrofon? Ja, das... Das hat nicht mal ein Kabel. Ja, nee, nee. Das ist keine Illusion, das hat kein Kabel. Ja, da kann ich nicht dafür sagen, das ist immer durch. Ich glaube, wir kommen schnell durch M, ehrlich gesagt, Mikrofon, Mikrowelle, keine Ahnung. Oh mein, Kollege, keine Ahnung. Wo wir gerade bei das Leben beenden waren, man kann sich sehr einfach das Leben nehmen. Weiderweg habe ich auch noch nicht viel von gehört, aber tatsächlich eigentlich auch eine sehr praktische Lösung, besser als vielleicht sich vor den Zug werfen, weil man keine anderen Menschen in den Mitleidenschaft, wobei wir kommen gleich dazu wahrscheinlich doch, wenn jetzt wo ich zu Ende denke, und zwar den Kopf in die Mikrowelleelle da musst du dann irgendwas halt da reinstecken dass die mikrowelle denkt sich wer zu
sonst geht die nicht an weil die smart smart muss ich dich ja hier an der stelle unterbrechen oder wir haben eine schlagzeile nächste woche die grossen pufu-tode 2020 die besten drei wege sich umzubringen. Top drei?
Nein.
Ja.
Hm.
Ich glaube, also ich, also ich Die ersten drei Wege sich umzubringen, Top drei.
Ich glaube, also ich ... Ich finde das klatschenschwieriger als den Gag.
Nein, ich würde sagen ...
Ich finde das klatschenschwieriger.
Vor allem, man will ja glaube ich auch auf eine coole Art gehen.
Ich würde es glaube ich erst mit einer Mehlexplosion versuchen.
Wie gesagt, mein Wunschton immer noch Mehlexplosion.
Da ist ja krasse Verbrennungen.
Das ist ja das Problem. Und dann guckst du mal weiter.
Aber ich würde erst mal unten anfangen und mich dann hocharbeiten. Aber das ist, glaube ich, schwierig. Ja, wie gesagt, also Mikrowelle und dann platzt halt dein Kopf. Ja, ja. Du brälst halt dein Hirn. Ja. Und dann ist auch nicht geil für die Leute, die dich dann finden. Aber gibt es nicht in solchen Situationen manchmal so die Forensikleute, die dann kommen und sagen, Wir haben hier ein schön gares Hirn, wollen wir nicht kurz einmal einlöffeln probieren? Drann nippen. Einfach mal dran nippen. Wir haben hier so viel Gehirnsach. Was ist denn Heggis nochmal? Ich glaube, es ist sehr nah dran. Glaube ich, keiner ist so so. Auch Hirn. Irgendwas im... Heggis ist doch Hirn. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Magen. Was? Innerein. Ihr habt auch keine Ahnung. Innerein. Fast alles ausser Haut ist innerein. Von daher denkt das relativ viel ab. Aber gut, es hat sich schlecht. Es hat sich zumindest schon mal in Worten. Nicht so schlecht, wie tief muss man graben, um das Wort innerein. Also sind Zähne schon innerein? Nein, weil die ja auch eine Oberfläche sind. Ja, das ist schwierig, weil das nicht so alles, was man nicht zweimal hat, ist Innerein oder irgendwie so ein Bullshit, oder irgendwie so ein Crap, irgendeine dumme Definition gab es. Also Nieren sind keine Innerein. Ich habe doch keine Ahnung, N, N bin ich blank, N, Nieren, keine Ahnung, was kommt nach N, weiss ich nicht. Oh, Otto von Bismarck, Regierungszeit. Und Wasserhersteller. Ah, bisher gut, unser das gute, herbe Bismarckwasser. Warum hat man auf der Bühne immer so kleine Wasserflaschen? Ich weiss nicht. Ich habe noch niemand gesehen mit so einer Liter Woldingflasche. Das ist ja immer geil. So ein Wasserspender einfach so. Mit langer Abend. Ich nehme pro Abend 20 Kilo ab und dann denke ich mir doch, dann will ich doch auf einem vernünftigen Litereimer hier haben. Oder einfach so wie bei einer Bar, so ein Zapfhaar. Das finde ich eigentlich auch ganz gut. Das war das Unangenehmste, das glaubt einem keiner, deswegen habe ich das nicht zu erzählen, weil das niemand glaubt. Egal was jetzt kommt, ich glaub's dir. Ich glaub dir das stimmt. Und zwar, ich war ja in Wien, in der schönen Stadt Wien. Wien, per Zug oder was? Ähm, ja. Okay. Lange Fahrt, lange Fahrt. Aber lohnt sich, schöne Stadt. Ja, man fährt ja lange hin, das stimmt. Ja, ja. Ich werde das Rauschneiden davor, ne? Nein. Dann wissen wir das. Nein. Wieso? Du willst es verhindern, dass es rauschneiden. Und dann war ich da und dann war da halt, das war ein Beethoven-Konzert und das war wirklich sehr lang. Weil das Konzept des Konzertes war, man muss sagen, Beethoven war wirklich ein unglaubliches Arschloch, ein unglaublicher Vollidiot, kann man auch sagen. Blöthofen könnte man fast sogar sagen. Ludwig von Blöthofen, Lollo von Blöthofen. Wirklich, wir sind ja in unserer Reihe, wir haben auch schon Da Vinci entlarvt, ne, Dumm Vinci, Blöthofen, gucken wir noch so kommt, aber das Konzept des Konzertes war, ein Konzert von 1808 nachzustellen. Und zwar hat er im Dezember 1808 in Wien, hat Beethoven ein sehr langes Konzert gegeben, das ging viereinhalb Stunden. Und er hatte da die fünfte Sinfonie hatte Premiere, die sechste hatte Premiere, Milliarden Klavierkonzerte hatten Premiere, so eine Chorfantasie hatte Premiere, alles Premiere. Unfassbar, und das sind ja auch wirklich Werke, die so ein bisschen die Welt verändert haben in der Musik. Und trotzdem haben alle Leute danach, alle Zeitgenossen, die dann da waren, geschrieben, holy shit war dieser Abend lang, und das zog sich, holy shit, das zog sich. Und alle waren sich auch einig, und alle Journalisten auch damals haben sich auch danach gesagt, ja, das war schon krass, also, da war, babababa, da war cool, aber ich habe keine Erinnerung mehr daran, weil das so lang war. Und die haben sich wirklich, also alle Journalisten haben sich geeinigt darauf, es nicht zu besprechen, sondern einfach zu sagen, es war viel zu lang. Und in Wien hat man sich gedacht, ja, stellen wir es nach. Und dann haben sie es nachgestellt. Das geht sich schon aus. Und ich habe mich schon gewundert, warum die Karten so billig war. Und es war ewig lang. Und dann haben sie nicht nur überlegt, wir spielen alle Songs von damals, sondern wir spielen auch die gleiche Setlist. Und dann haben sie wirklich in der gleichen Reihenfolge, muss ich sagen, Blöthofen hat wirklich eine dumme Setlist gewählt. Es fing nämlich nicht geil an und es hat auch nicht geil aufgehört. Es war einfach, inzwischen war man ein Highlight, aber dazwischen zog sich wirklich ganz, ganz doll. Und dann war vor mir, und das ist der Part, den an niemand glaubt, war irgendwo, ich habe es nicht orten können, aber an irgendeinem Punkt, das war ein leises Stück, hörte man einfach nur so ein Es lief etwas aus. Und in diesem ganzen Saal waren nur ganz alte Menschen, es ging ewig lang und holy shit und ich glaube einfach, dass da so ein Katheterbeutel geplatzt ist, ein Loch hatte und es ging bestimmt fünf Minuten, lief da was runter. Und du hast auch gehört, das war ein Teppichboden, und man weiss ja, wenn Flüssigkeit, wenn du lange auf Teppichboden gehst, ist erst noch so dumpfes, so ein dumpfes Knistern, und irgendwann ist dann Flüssigkeit auf Flüssigkeit, das ist typische Plätschern. Und so, und das ging ewig. Und der ganze Saal hat sich so in dieses, hat dieses Epizentrum gesucht, und hat dann so umgeguckt und so, und auch alle Orchestermitglieder waren dann irgendwann schon so verwehrt, weil das war halt auch wahnsinnig laut dann irgendwann, weil irgendwann war halt Wasser auf Wasser und das war so widerlich wirklich und es ging ewig und irgendwann ging es auch zu lang, um sich darüber aufzuregen oder das irgendwie zu empfinden und war auch schon wieder, war man in den Gedanken auch schon wieder woanders, weil das so lange dauert hat, man konnte sich nicht mehr darauf konzentrieren und hat man wieder nach vorne geguckt und so, aber es lief halt immer noch weiter. Das war wirklich, ich habe es nicht rausgefunden und so, ich habe auch irgendwie nicht die Lust gehabt in der Pause, ich war eigentlich sehr froh über die Pause, weil so viel Beethoven, holy shit und dann bin ich auch raus, aber eigentlich hätte ich mal noch suchen sollen, ob da irgendwo ein grosser so Lache lag, aber das war wirklich ganz, ganz eklig. Ach du Scheiße, ja, vielleicht auch, jaer Mord einfach, jemanden schmelzen während so einem Konzert. Oh mein Gott. Einfach irgendwie sowas. Schmelzen vor sich hin. Aber ich habe die grössten Tarn, die ich bei so Konzerten immer habe, ist, dass irgendwie doch mein Handy losgeht oder sowas. Als hatte ich mal neulich, da habe ich zu lange irgendwie auf die Austaste gedrückt, dann ging dieser Notfall-Alarm an. Habe ich noch nie gehabt, aber dann ging so ein ,, so ein ganz lautes Geräusch ging dann plötzlich an und seitdem in dem Konzert konnte ich ja nichts an, also schön, babababa, auch ganz toll, aber da habe ich die ganze Zeit an mein Handy gedacht, was dieses Geräusch erzeugen könnte und das ist einfach nichts unangenehmer, ausser halt der Katerbeutel läuft da aus, das ist noch ein bisschen unangenehmer, aber das war wirklich ganz, ganz schlimm. Ja. Also wie gesagt, glaubt einem niemand. Deswegen, es war, aber in dem Moment war das... Aber du hast danach nicht nachgeschaut,
Detective Connem-mässig, wer der Mörder war und so. Detective-Connor hat immer nachgeschaut. Jetzt mal Tür zu, einer von euch war's. Und dann war es so gut, immer auf 500 Leute. Aber es ist eine lange Folge, es ist ein Spielfilm, aber kann funktionieren. Detective-Connor-Spiel, ja. Ich weiss noch mal, ich habe ja früher als Kind Gitarre gespielt und dann gibt es auch diese Gitarrenkonzerte, immer ganz schrecklich, dann irgendwie jeder von grauenhaft schlecht bis schlecht ist dann so die ganzen Jahrgangsstufen durch. Ja, das wird immer besser, ne? Es wird immer besser, aber es wird nie gut. Es ist einfach furchtbar. Es ist wirklich das... Aber es ist eigentlich so ein bisschen schlimmste. Das DSDS-Prinzip, also von den schlimmen Leuten am Anfang in den Castings wird es halt immer besser. Ja, und tatsächlich war mein Vater dann auch anwesend, hat sich das angeschaut und das Handy von meinem Vater hat zwischen zwei Stücken geklingelt. Und einerseits dachte ich, Papa... Zwischen deinem oder von dem anderen Kind? Nee, zwischen zwei anderen. Einerseits dachte ich, Papa, warum machst du dein scheiß Handy nicht aus, auf der anderen Seite... Megatiming. Megatiming. Das ist wirklich perfektes Timing. Ich stücker aus, der andere kommt rein, super nervös mit Gitarre, und dann geht das Handy los und das war perfekt. War einfach perfekt. Ich war trotzdem wütend. War der Klingelton, Curb Your Enthusiasm oder sowas? Nee, das nicht. Ich weiß, es war irgendwie so, wie wahrscheinlich jeder Mensch über 40 den voreingestellten Handyton hat. Mittlerweile ja jeder eigentlich. Mittlerweile gibt es ja den Crazy Frog nicht mehr. Aber mittlerweile hat hier einfach jeder den. Ich weiß, warum hat sie... Marimba, das Marimba-Fohn-Ding, ne? Ja, Marimba. Das mittlerweile glaube ich auch viele spielen eigentlich. Wir haben auch das Problem, wenn man bei so einer Vorführung dann ist man Rimm und der gesamte Saal einfach so aufbremdlich bei jedem einzelnen Song. Das ist schon schwierig. Alle haben den gleichen, ja. Ich wollte so gerne wütend auf meinen Vater sein, aber es ging nicht, weil er hat nichts ruiniert im Grunde. Warum wollten Sie so wütend auf Ihren Vater sein? Ich weiß nicht, weil ich, naja, vielleicht kommt mein Hass auf Leute, die in solchen Situationen stören oder zu laut sind, aus dieser Situation, dass ich nie den Hass auf meinen Vater ausleben konnte. Fühlt sich manchmal nicht gehört von dem Vater, hört Ihr Vater Ihnen nicht zu? Ja, schon manchmal, ich hätte dann auch gerne Mac-Menü zu mitnehmen, wenn es geht, unabhängig davon. Auf dem Pommes, Mayo oder Ketchup, ich nehme immer nichts. Sie stellen immer so schwere Fragen. Ja, es stimmt, aber weisst du noch, wie man früher als Kind geübt hat, bevor man zum McDonald's gescheitert ging?
Achso, ich sagte vor, Kitarrenvorspiel.
Ne, das einfach nicht.
Wie man als Kind geübt hat, ich übe immer noch.
Ja?
Die Bestellung?
Ja, mittlerweile, ja, okay.
Na ja, mittlerweile ist es...
Ich übe die immer noch, beim Bäcker übe ich sofort.
Ja, beim Bäcker schon, aber so bei McDonald's so mit allen Nachfangen zu mitnehmen.
Ich spreche es mir immer vor, aber manchmal bin ich einfach morgens zu müde und ich verhaspele mich immer.
Ja.
Franzbrötchen, kann ich jetzt sagen, ist ja auch sehr spät schon, aber ich kann morgens nicht Franzbrötchen sagen.
Ne, es ist eine schwierige Bestellung, vor allem, ich bin, glaube ich, das grösste Arschloch beim Bestellen und alle Service-Mitarbeiter, grosse Sorry an der Stelle, weil ich immer, wenn, weil ich, ich habe dann auch so, mittlerweile übe ich es nicht mehr, weil ich bestelle immer dasselbe, ich mache wirklich immer, immer dasselbe und ich sage immer zwei Laugenbrezeln zum mitnehmen bitte und dann wenn jemand sagt, wie viel, dann sage ich immer nochmal zwei Laugenbrezeln zum mitnehmen bitte, ich wiederhole wirklich den exakt Satz, weil du das typst hast, alles andere wäre off script, alles andere wäre im Pro. Ein Arschloch rögen oder einfach zwei Laugenbräste mitnehmen bitte. Zum Mitnehmen, zwei Laugenbräste zum Mitnehmen.
Zwei Laugenbräste.
Einfach so.
Und wenn dann eine Gegenfrage kommt, soll ich die einpacken, dann muss man erstmal wieder nachdenken, weil man hat einen Satz parat, alles andere wäre, hu, Impro, wirklich Impro. Dann krieg ich immer die kleinen Brezel, weil die mich hassen alle. Ich kenne diese ganz winzigen, diese ganz kleinen, wo ich mich auch immer beschweren will, weil dann krieg ich immer die kleinen. Und dann deutet man, es gibt die Leute, die dann auch extra noch drauf beuten, wo ich denke, die ganz klar wissen, was sie haben wollen. Ja, wo ich mir denke, eines Tages will ich auch so ein Deutscher werden. Du willst ein Deutscher werden? Ich hab noch nicht genug Selbstbewusstsein, um Deutscher zu sein. Ich finde die monopatisch. Nee, eines Tages wirklich, bei so Bäckereien gibt es ja immer wirklich so haufenweise Brezeln und die dann wirklich sagen, ich hätte gerne die da, wo man hier einen, die Kurve da sieht, die da ganz hinten unten links.
Es ist immer diese wenige Gesten.
Nee, nee, unter, drunter, drunter, drunter, alles gleich.
Es sind diese sehr vagen Gesten immer so, die auf alles deuten könnten, aber auch immer dieses lakonische Grinsen immer dabei ist.
Nee, die immer so kurz vor, eigentlich nach selber sind.
Sie wissen schon, welche. Sie würden die auch nehmen, welche würden Sie nehmen. Ja, weil ich denke mir so, jeder der nach dir ist, kriegt ja dann die schlechteren, so, wenn du immer den besten nimmst, das ist einfach mega asozial, aber du kannst eigentlich nicht nach so einer Bestellung dann sagen, ja ich hätte gerne irgendeine, so, weil dann kriegst du die schlechtere. Das ist so ein Arschlochverhalten, das ist so Domino-Arschloch, der dann alles nach ihm auch noch schlechter macht, weil alle dann denken, jetzt muss ich es auch machen, damit ich eine gute kriege. Weil er hat schon eine bessere bekommen als Edition, also will man auch eine haben. Ja, gestern war Bäcker und da wollte jemand, hat mir dann einen Bagel, so einen Schinken-Bagel, weggeschnappt und hat dann noch eine Apfel-Zimtschnecke genommen. Und dann wollte ich auch diesen Bagel und habe mir gesagt, nee, den hat der Mann vorhin gekauft, Ich habe dann so gesagt, ja, sorry. Und dann habe ich aber danach auch noch eine Apfel-Zimtschnecke genommen. Und dann wollte ich auch diesen Bagel und habe gesagt, den hat der Mann vorhin gekauft. Er hat dann so gesagt, ja, sorry. Und dann habe ich aber danach auch noch eine Apfel-Zimtschnecke bestellt und habe zu ihm gesagt, ja, die konnten Sie mir jetzt nicht mehr wegkaufen, oder? Und war eigentlich so ein bisschen angepisst. Wow, Stefan! Nicht schlecht, Stefan schlägt zu. Vorsicht, die sind teuer. Die Mikrofone sind teuer. Sorry, wenn da was dran ist, bezahl ich das. Bezahlen das Prominente, wenn die einen Mic-Drop gemacht haben danach? Ich weiss nicht. Oder sind die zu cool und bezahlen das dann nicht? Aber die haben doch genug Geld. Ja, stimmt schon. Also die zerstörten Hotelzimmer. Aber der hat dann sehr, sehr gelacht. Der hat wirklich, das war, der hat ganz, ganz laut gelacht danach. Und der hat sich mir, geil, vielleicht ist das meine Person, ich muss einfach mehr zum Arschloch werden. Ja. Und dann nehmen das Leute vielleicht als Witz wahr. Ich glaube, es steht dir auch viel besser, es steht dir, glaube ich, viel besser. Ja. Das ist eine neue Lebensphase, du hast immer verschiedene Phasen. Du hattest die Kunstphase, jetzt hast du die Arschlochphase, wo du einfach dann anfangen... Jetzt habe ich die Einrichtungsphase, wo ich umziehe, habe ich jetzt so eine Interior-Design-Phase. Und das Gute bei Netflix ist, dass es da alles gibt. Viele Sachen gibt es bei Netflix, finde ich mega Anbieter, also würde ich sagen, der beste Screening-Anbieter. In letzter Zeit haben die ein bisschen nachgelassen. Nee, würde ich jetzt gar nicht so sagen. Ich finde gerade Damen, die gerade in Deutschland auch viel an den Start gebracht. Das ist auch eine gute deutsche Serie. Naja, jedenfalls habe ich da angefangen Interior Design Masters, weil ich dachte, vielleicht hilft mir das bei meiner Wohnung und so. Aber dann haben die immer so Hotels und Schlösser und so eingerichtet. Es war nicht relatable, noch nicht relatable. Aber die letzte Finale war relatable, weil da mussten sie einfach Wohnungen einrichten. Normale Everyday-Wohnungen war aber das Finale und dann wollten die sich beide so super ausleben, weil das der Preis für, wenn du Interior Design Masters gewinnst, da wurden nämlich so, also nicht acht, neun, zehn junge Designer wurden dann da eingeladen, mussten dann die Wohnungen designen und die beiden, einer hat halt gewonnen und der bekommt dann so einen grossen Auftrag und darf dann wirklich so eine neue Bar in London oder so ausstatten.
Also eigentlich ein ganz geiler Preis und dann wollten die halt unbedingt zeigen, dass sie es so super drauf haben, aber das Finale war halt ein bisschen unnötig gewählt, das waren einfach normale Wohnungen. Und dann kamen sie vorher dann zu den normalen Leuten, die da drin wohnen und die haben einfach eigentlich gesagt, wir wollen eigentlich hier gerne so eine Leseke haben und hier halt Sofa, wir haben alle Menschen Sofa und Fernseher und Küche und da hinten, wir haben ein Kinderzimmer und ein Schlafzimmer. Und die Thierry Design-Masters dachten auch so, okay, wie verwirkliche ich mich hier selbst, weil ich will ja diese Bar-Design halt. Und in beiden Häusern haben die unterschiedlich voneinander interviewt, waren die Familien halt denkbar, ja, macht mir einfach eine normale Wohnung. Und beide waren so irgendwie, keine Ahnung, was ich so machen soll. Und dann haben natürlich beide sich trotzdem irgendwie verwirklicht und haben halt so blumige Tapeten genommen, wahnsinnig viel Farbe, haben die ganze Wand abgerissen, irgendwie eine andere raufgezogen, so ein Regal in Wand, Verschachtelung und so weiter.
Und es waren am Ende die realesten zwei Wohnungen in aller Zeiten.
Es war super seltsam.
Und dann gab es halt diesen Moment, der immer das Befriedigendste an diesen Shows ist,
dass am Ende dann die Paare wieder reinkommen in ihre Wohnung und ihre Wohnung sehen
und immer denken, holen, weinen, weil es nicht so schön, die können sich das nicht vorstellen.
Und in den beiden Wohnungen kamen die Paare rein und waren so
Wow!
Wow, ein Aquarium in der Wand!
Der ganze Boden ist ein Pädenbad.
Wirklich!
Wahnsinn!
Aber trotzdem nicht, weil diese Musik drüber, diese
Neues gutes Leben, ja genau. Diese geile RTL2-Musik, wo man sagt, wow, alles wird besser, aber die Gesichter haben gesagt, oh mein Gott, nein, nein, die Gesichter waren Simon & Garfbanker. Aber haben Sie den Punkt gekriegt, wo Sie ehrlich geworden sind? Nee. There are many different things that I can do. There are many different things that I can do. There are many different things that I can do. There are many different things that I can do, we regret doing it. I gotta leave the room right now. Und dann bin ich einfach zu heulen. Und dann bin ich einfach zu heulen. Und dann bin ich einfach zu heulen. Und dann bin ich einfach so, do you like anything? Und der Typ nur so, no. Einfach irgendwie so, und dann kommt schon so der Abspann rein und die Moderatorin so, ja, dann bis nächste Woche, mach's gut, ciao. Und es ist fantastisch, es ist grossartig. Das hätte ich mir die ganze Zeit gewünscht, aber wahrscheinlich, und dann denke ein Abspann rein und die Unternehmens so, ja, dann bis nächste Woche, mach's gut, ciao und es ist fantastisch, es ist grossartig.
Das hätte ich mir die ganze Zeit gewünscht, aber wahrscheinlich, und dann denke ich mir auch so, dann gehen das Kamerateam geht und die Designer gehen und so, und dann stehen die in dieser Wohnung und denken, holy shit, was machen wir jetzt, ist das so eine Show, wo die einen noch mal besuchen, um zu gucken, ob man immer noch in dieser Wohnung liegt, wie Rach, bei Rach der Restauranttester, wo die nach Jahren noch mal wiedergekommen sind und dann wissen wollten, ob es immer noch gut läuft und dann weiß man ja nicht, ist das jetzt gerade eine Show, wo wir mitgemacht haben, wo die danach noch mal kommen und gucken, ob man sich eingelebt hat oder so, oder können wir das jetzt alles wegschmeißen? Das ist die viel bessere Show eigentlich, der Designer kommt ein Jahr später und sagt so, ah, ich sehe, Sie haben die Tapete abgerissen. Und dann wieder die Abente abgerissen, die wieder in ein Hotel stecken und wieder genau so einrichten. Ja, genau. Und dann irgendwann diesen Vertrag zeigen, so einen shitty Vertrag, wo das halt drinsteht, so eine Klausel, die alle überlesen, weil die mit so einer Zaubertimpe geschrieben ist. Kann man das machen? Das ist eine geile Idee, einfach immer wieder. Und dann irgendwie, dann heisst es so, ja, Sie nehmen jetzt teil bei irgendeiner Reiseshow und Sie fliegen irgendwo hin, Sie wurden aus der Welt irgendwie nach Mallorca zu fliegen und während die wechseln, macht man wieder die Wohnung neu und Sie kommen zurück und by the way, wir haben auch noch Ihre Wohnung neu gemacht und Sie stehen wieder vor der exakt gleichen Wohnung. Ja, aber die lesen doch nur bis, sie bekommen umsonst eine Wohnung, ja, die lesen die Verträge darüber und sie bekommen umsonst eine Wohnung neu eingerichtet. Weiter lesen sie den Vertrag doch nicht. Aber dann gibt's doch Paragraph 23. Und ein Jahr später irgendwie sie, wir wollen so eine Prankshow bei Ihnen drehen, wir wollen Ihren Nachbarn pranken, wir brauchen die als Haus für eine Woche. Wenn Sie meine Wohnung noch mal neu einrichten, wenn ich diese Blumenvorhänge noch einmal sehe, kriege ich Ihr Wort, dass Sie sie nicht neu einrichten? Ja, kriegen Sie, ja klar. I just got ha ha ha ha.
Woche später die Blumentapete einfach wieder.
Jesus Christ. Aber ich muss sagen, ich habe tatsächlich keine Ahnung von Immobilien und es interessiert mich auch nicht wirklich.
Und ich kann damit mit diesem Begriff noch immer nichts anfangen, habe aber gemerkt, dass sehr viele Leute sehr...
Immobilie kommt von Immobile, unbeweglichen Latein.
Aber ich habe auch jetzt gemerkt, über die Feiertage und Weihnachten und so, dass anscheinend erwachsene Menschen und ja, ich schließe mich jetzt hier mal aus, erwachsene Menschen sehr gerne über Immobilien in Einrichtungen reden. Und dann sagt er immer so, ja, ich habe jetzt eine Wohnung, überlege ich mir jetzt zu kaufen, die ist 43 Quadratmeter. Bei mir im Kopf wirklich nur so wirklich fünfte Klasse Matheunterricht Quadratmeter, das heisst 20 mal 20 mal 20 mal so und wirklich so dieses Zac Galifianakis-Gel. Wenn man die Taschenbrecher-App rauskommt. Genau, also das ist ein Meter mal dreiundvierzig Meter, das ist ungefähr auf dem Edeka-Parkplatz, also ungefähr vom restlichen Gesprächsgriech. Und dann fällt da immer nur so ein Quadrat ein, aber dann sind Wohnungen ja kein Quadrat, dann haben Wohnungen zählen Wände mit, Wände nehmen ja Platz weg. Ja, es ist jetzt 42 Quadratmeter, aber halt recht hoch, also ungefähr 7000 Kubikmeter, also da muss man, und ich so, da kann ich ein Taschenrechen haben. Und dann bist du da mit deinem Lineal, deinem Geodreieck aus Mathe und baust das so nach und denkst, das kann nicht funktionieren. Und dann laden dich zum ersten Mal abends ein zum Dinner und du kommst da hin und du bist aber im Turm. Einfach ein Meter mal einen Meter und irgendwie sieben Haummeter hoch. So ein Schornstein. Schön geworden. Ich glaube, mit dem richtigen Teppich kann das gut funktionieren.
Ja.
Ich steig da einfach sofort aus irgendwie.
Ich glaube, ich könnte auch wirklich in so einem Sargleben einfach, wirklich in so einem.
Ja.
Unentsummobile zu werden, aber ich glaube, je weniger Platz ich habe, desto besser.
Und ich glaube, das ist auch für den Rückenstil.
Stimmt, lass mal nicht mobile werden.
Ne, nicht so mobile.
Aber es ist einfach ... Ne, weil das ist ja spannend, du lebst ja wirklich denkbar minimalistisch. Ja, du nennst es minimalistisch, die Leute denken dann an so ein cooles minimalistisches Design. Nee, ich wollte auch, dachte ich auch gerade, aber es ist kahl, nichts, du lebst leer, du hast keine Möbel. Wenn ich dich nicht gezwungen hätte, hättest du nicht mal ein Bett. Ich würde euch ganz kurz mal eine Szene exemplarisch darlegen, die vielleicht meine Wohnsituation darstellt. Ich bin vor eineinhalb Jahren in die Wohnung eingezogen. Ich sitze an meinem Schreibtisch, auf dem Computer vor mir, ich schaue mir ein YouTube-Video an, so merke plötzlich, ich kann meinen Monitor gar nicht mehr so gut sehen, weil das Sonnenlicht direkt durch das Fenster auf mich scheint. Hm, was mache ich dagegen? Ich nehme einfach einen der Umzugskartons und stelle ihn auf meine Mateflaschen, auf das Fensterbrett, um das Sonnenlicht davon zu hindern, meinen Schreibtisch zu treffen. Das ist die Situation. Ke keine Vorhänge, vergiss es, es ist wirklich genau so und sonst habe ich nichts in meiner Wohnung. Du hast einen Umzugskarton? Ich habe immer noch die Umzugskarton. Leere Mateflaschen? Ganz viele leere Mateflaschen. Ein Schreibtisch, wie kam das? Bist du in deinen Laden gegangen? Ach so. Ja, vor allem ich bin zu Ikea gegangen und ich hatte ein Car2Go Smart. Und ich dachte mir, okay, pass auf. Das ist nur so viel kaufen, wie in dieses Auto passt, was halt dann irgendwie am Ende 16 Hotdogs in ein Schreibtisch war. Und dann fahre ich halt mit 16 Hotdogs in ein Schreibtisch und dann war es das halt auch. Und mehr brauche ich dann auch nicht. Wie geht ein Schreibtisch in Smart? Ja, zusammenklappen schön. Schön zusammenklappen, Vorderlehne hinten und dann hast du halt Kofferraum offen. Kofferraum offen? Kofferraum immer offen. Immer offen. Weil dann fühlt man sich, als hätte man ein Auto mit Spoiler. Das ist viel cooler. Ich fahre immer mit offenem Kofferraum. Du hast mehr Abrieb, du hast mehr Abrieb. Das ist eher auf der Strasse. Man fühlt sich schneller einfach. Es ist einfach besser. Und ich fühle mich so ein bisschen wie bei Knight Rider, der ja auch immer diesen Lastwagen hatte, wo er hinten in den Lastwagen reingefahren ist. Ja. Und viele identifizieren sich wahrscheinlich mit Kit und denken, oh, der ist schnell, der ist cool. Ich habe mich immer mit dem Lastwagen geingefiziert und dachte mir immer so, geil, dann mache ich die Klappe auf und so, dann nehme ich Leute auf. Und deswegen mag es auch immer ganz gerne, ein Auto zu fahren mit dem Kofferraum einfach offen. weil ich mir immer vorstelle dann fahren da andere Leute rein und so. Ich finde das einfach eine schöne Vorstellung. Und das heißt du hast also einen Schreibtisch, den hast du gekauft, für andere Möbel war kein Platz im Smart, du kannst ja mehrere Trips, du hast ja zweimal hinfahren im Smart, auch so aufwendig. Ja vor allem, ich hatte lange kein Bett, sondern eine Matratze, die auf dem Boden lag, und dann kam mein Nachbar an und meinte, ja, ich kaufe mir jetzt ein neues Bett, wollen Sie mein altes Bett haben? Und dann hatte ich anscheinend so einen zweifelnden Blick im Gesicht, so dass er gesagt hat, nee, ich kann Ihnen auch helfen, Ihr altes Bett wegzubringen. Und ich so, boah, ja, das ist nicht nötig. Ich muss den Fuss in den Blick gestellt, wenn ich auf die Idee komme. Ich glaube, das ist gar nicht nötig. Dankeschön. Und dann, seitdem habe ich ein Bett. Und so kam das einfach. Der hat mein Nachbar gesagt, wollen Sie ein Bett? Ich habe nicht Nein gesagt, ich habe jetzt im strengsten Sinne auch nicht Ja gesagt, aber dann hatte ich ein Bett. Das Universum provided Bett. Ja, vor allem, und dann dachte ich, ich hatte lange in Berlin, hatte ich, vor allem, ich dachte mir so, Bett ist eigentlich das uncoole Teil des Betts. Was cool ist, ist die Matratze. Also ist es nicht klug, das Bett durch noch eine Matratze zu ersetzen, weil du hast das, was gut ist, doppelt. Das ist so wie wenn du irgendwann merkst, dass du statt Brot, Wurst auch Wurstwurst essen kannst. Ach so? Der Brotteil ist nicht der, der Brot ist so wie wenn du irgendwann merkst, dass du statt Brotwurst auch Wurstwurst essen kannst.
Der Brotteil ist nicht der, der gut ist so.
Ja, der Brotteil ist schon immer ganz geil.
Du kannst auch einfach beides.
Ich dachte gerade ein Brötchen in Brötchen.
Das ist dann die andere Situation, ja, eine Brotstulle.
Schmierst du dir schön.
Zwei Bettgestelle übereinander, auch nicht so schlecht.
Aber du weißt schon, dass die Matratze auch durchs Bett geiler wird, also durch vor allem das Lattenrost. Glaube ich nicht dran. Zwei Matratzen. Klar, ich weiß, dass ich gerade gesagt habe, dass ich so dermaßen Rückschen mehr Schmerzen hatte, dass ich geschlafen konnte. Hilft deinem Punkt nicht. Es sind zwei Punkte, die wir gerne zusammenfügen. Nee, auf jeden Fall, da hatte ich zwei Matratzen und dachte eigentlich, das ist es eigentlich. Und dann war ich einmal, das war ein ganz merkwürdiges Wochenende, war ich mal auf der Spielemesse in Essen, ganz merkwürdig, und dann hieß es so, ah ja, hier ein Zimmer wurde sie für gebucht, ich kam in ein Zimmer, Wasserbett. Und es war auch so, okay, ich wurde nicht gewarnt, dass das jetzt das Wasserbettzimmer ist, so einfach völlig, ah okay, gut, Zimmer, da hatte ich ein Wasserbett und es war eine tolle Nacht.
Ich meine, ich konnte nicht schlafen, weil ich die ganze Zeit so blub, blub, blub, blub, blub. Es ist wie wenn man sehr viel Wasser getrunken hat und vom Sport zum Beispiel, dann joggt und man, das ist das Geräusch.
Ja, und ich habe als Jugendlicher einen Sitzsack bekommen, der, ja, ich war übergewichtig, innerhalb kürzester Zeit explodiert ist. Und seitdem... Sitzsack-Explosion. Und vor allem, du sitzt in so einem Sitzsack, machst da so rum und plötzlich so wumm und du denkst dir, und plötzlich kommt dir das erste Mal in den Sinn, was da drin ist. Was ist eigentlich in so einem Sitzsack drin? Und es sind diese Kichererbsen-artigen. Was war es dann? Es waren kleine Styroporkügelchen, die ich einfach den Rest meiner gesamten Jugendlichkeit in den Haaren aufbauen. Bis zum Abitur in den Haaren hatte. Man putzt sich so die Zähne und schwimmt da aus, das ist ja so ein Styroporkönig. Wie viel? Du schläfst das so an, wie andere Leute so Sand vom Strand in die Wohnung tragen.
Aber das Beste war Florentin hier, das war immer eine geile Detective-Corn-Folge.
Am Ende präsentiert er so ein Styropor-Corn.
Das Beste war natürlich das Gesicht der Katze, die einfach straight von oben bis unten mit so Styroporkönigchen, die panisch den Raum verlassen hat und du wusstest so, okay, patient zero, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0 erfüllen und dachte, irgendwann kommt dieses Moment, wo einfach alles platzt unter mir und das ist einfach, dann ist auch wieder, ist da wirklich Wasser drin? Und das ist genau das Gleiche mit diesem Gefühl. Das ist wie die Schneek immer mit gel ich denke da ist immer gel drin aber ich war nicht wirklich sicher nicht sicher nicht so recht ist wasser drin wahrscheinlich aber das wird sogar selber auffüllen manchmal nachfüllen aber das wird auch das wird auch nicht gewechselt wird das gewechselt das ja vor allem das ist halt auch nicht. Ja, aber wenn du so ein Wasserbett aufmachst, das ist Wasser aus den Sechzigern. Aber wir kriegen sonst ja immer so einen Pfähze. Ich meine, das ist Wasser, hallo, ich mein's ernst, das ist altes Wasser. Das ist Wasser aus China, aus China in den Sechzigern. Ja, chinesisches altes Wasser, das ist eine Rarität. Das ist aus dem Ganges in Indien, schön hat man mal einmal durchgewedelt. Ja, dachte ich mir auch, weil das Wasserbett war nicht durchsichtig, das kann auch dreckiges Wasser sein, kann schmutziges Wasser sein, weiss niemand, niemand weiss das. Wie entsorgt man ein Wasserbett? Also haut man das so in den Container rein, wie so ein ganz trauriges Ding einfach, oder lässt man da das Wasser ab, wenn man es in Saal hat? Oder Pfandautomat, wo halt Dinge stehen, wo man Flüssigkeit drin war. Oder wirft man es dann auch in den Fluss oder so was, der dann auch denkt, Leute, das ist ja echt eine gute Frage. Weiss irgendwer, was im Wasserbett, ob man das wechseln muss? Ja. Ja. Haben wir gedacht. Aber auch kein zufriedener Wasserbettkunde. Ja, ja, fragst du nicht mal, wie oft man das wechseln muss, so eine Antwort war das eigentlich. So ein You don't wanna know. Aber da ist schon einfach normales Wasser drin von zu Hause. Das ist ein spezielles Wasserbettwasser, klar, die Wasserbettlobby macht dann natürlich gross Cash und verkauft das dann so in 0,3 Flaschen.
Und das sind so 120.000 Stück.
Aber die kosten auch jeweils so acht Euro. Aber das ist halt echt das Wasserbettwasser. Ich weiß nicht, was da reinkommt. Ich kaufe Wasserbettwasser. Und das darf man auch nicht trinken. Und da steht ja ganz gross drauf, auf gar keinen Fall trinken, einfach nur damit es so ein bisschen wertvoller wirkt. Das ist eine gute Idee. Ah ja, man will es dann sofort trinken. Warum haben wir eigentlich beim Wasserbett aufgehört? Wo ist der Wasserstuhl? Wo ist der Wasserstuhl? Wo ist die Wasserhängematte? Wo ist der Wasserboden? Wo ist das Wasserhaus? Dass die ganze Wohnung so ist wie so auf dem Mond, wie eine Mondlandschaft. Ja. Oder wie so ein Trampolin. Warum ist es nicht der ganze Boden Trampolin bei Leuten, die reich sind?
Da gibt es auch so in den Netflix-Serien dann über so sehr reiche Wohnungen, das ist auch so interior-designartig, und dann zeigen die dann, führen die dann durch ihre 300 Millionen Dollar Villen in Los Angeles und so. Und jedes Mal denke ich mir, das ist alles, was ihr mit eurem Geld erreichen wollt, dann würde ich auch sofort auf eine Trampolin-Boden-Idee oder so kommen. Das alles ist wie ein Jump House. Boden wie Jump House. Die sagen dann, nee, wir wollen dann Teakholz aus dem Urwald oder so. Nein, Jump House-Boden aus Köln, Kürth. Direkt Bowling-Baden, einfach Bowling-Baden direkt in der Küche. Einfach, dass man schon direkt morgens einfach Bowlen kann. Fände ich perfekt. Ja, Bowlingbahn haben wir. Ja, eigene Bowlingbahn? Ja. Manche das heilen wir sich mit Lachen. Stell dir vor, du wachst um drei Uhr nachts auf, kannst nicht schlafen und sagst und machst Yoga auf der Bowlingbahn. Nein, ich geh bowlen jetzt einfach, ich geh jetzt einfach bowlen, mach ich jetzt bowlen, geh ich alleine, schalte die Maschine an, die Bowlenmaschine an, zack, und dann gehe ich bowlen. Es gibt bestimmt irgendwie so eine alte Bowlingbahn, die irgendwie verschollen wurde. So die eine Bowlingbahn, auf der jeder mal gespielt haben will, eigentlich so aus Elfenbeinen und so. Gibt es da nicht so wichtige? Elfenbeinen? Ja. Ja. Vielleicht. Ich weiß, ist es nicht so, dass diese Streifen, die die anzeigen, was es ist, dass es so aus Kinderzähnen ist oder so? Das stimmt. Kinderzähne aus den Sechzigern, glaube ich. Die sind jetzt schon tot, die Leute. Das sind ganz viele alte Leute. Das ist ganz faszinierend, diese Boy-G-Wahn. Aber ich muss gerade denken, es gibt ja Menschen, die haben Ziele im Leben. Habe ich gehört. Also jetzt nicht irgendwie, ah, ich will glücklich sein, irgendwie so, sondern einfach die so konkrete Dinge machen, so ich will einmal auf der Elfenbein-Bowlingbahn spielen, die wirklich sagen, ich will einmal in dem und dem, ich will einmal Luftball, irgendwie so, ich will einmal den und den Türen treffen. Einmal den Luftballon halten. Ich will einmal in Luftballon halten. Und letztens habe ich herausgefunden, dass ich eine Person kenne, die auch ein solches sehr konkretes Ziel hat. Jedenfalls sagt so, weisst du was, bevor ich sterbe, würde ich gern noch mal das machen. Und das war meine Mutter. Meine Mutter hat ein konkretes Ziel und ich dachte mir so, was könnte das sein? Einfach mal noch. Es ist auch so, man lernt manchmal seine Eltern dann doch noch mal ganz kennen. Doch mal neu kennen. Das Testament war mir auch eine ganz neue Erfahrung. Ja. Man denkt dann manchmal, man kennt Eltern, sollte man kennen, wenn man einen Menschen kennt. Vor allem, wenn du, also so in Beziehungen ist es ja oft so, man lernt sich kennen, man datet und dann erzählt man sich so sein gesamtes Leben. Halt so, ja da Schule so und am Ende hat man alles erzählt und ab dann ist halt so business as usual, dann erzählt man nur noch, was so irgendwie jeden Tag passiert ist.
Ja, aber das Spannende ist, dann fangen Beziehungen und Freundschaften ja auch entspannen zu werden, wenn du diesen ganzen Kram hinter dir hast und keine Fragen gestellt werden müssen. Das ist aber das Problem, wenn du an Weihnachten nach Hause kommst und dich mal wieder auf deine alten Lotto freust, weil dann musst du wieder, irgendwann fängst du dann an, ja, was studierst du gerade und so. Erstmal muss man diese Catch-up-Fragen machen, und die sind nervig.
Und wenn die weg sind, dann wird der Abend wieder nett.
Und dann kann man über, wo sind wir eigentlich, und dann merkt man, dann wird die Stimmung wieder ganz lustig und warum sind wir auf einem Wasserboden, dann wird es nett, aber davor ist immer dieses, was studierst du gerade, und wie läuft, ich wohne gerade in Stuttgart, und dann ist das Gespräch auch auch vorbei. Nee, das willst du nicht, du willst alles schon im Hinterkopf haben, aber so bei den Eltern, bei deinen Eltern skippst du das erste Date. So, du hast nicht dieses, man erzählt sich mal alles, sondern man fängt schon an mit, wie war der Tag, so das erste, was man sagt, so wie war dein Tag. Ich habe vor drei Jahren erfahren, dass mein Vater schon mal verheiratet war. Ja? Ja, habe ich super spät erfahren. Ja, man redet da selten drüber. Wann redet man drüber? Vor allem, das ist doch keine Frage, die dir auf der Zunge liegt. Ja, genau. Ach, übrigens, Papa, warst du schon mal verheiratet? Wann jemanden was von den Klössen haben? Das war Gott nicht, diese Frage. Aber auch so als Vater so, ja, wir brauchen ein paar neue Müllsäcke, die sind wieder aus. Und ich war schon mal verheiratet. Und wir brauchen auch noch Schokofresh für Kinder, mag ich ganz klar. Ja, genau. Nee, und dann war das so eine Fake-Ehe, deswegen, ich weiss nicht mehr warum. Fake-Ehe? Ich habe aber vergessen, warum. Das ist doch, ich weiss nicht mehr warum. Reich ich nach. Da musst du echt mal nachregen, wir müssen deinen Vater mal einladen. Vor allem, wie kannst du denn nicht nachfragen, wie kannst du sagen, du übrigens, ich mag ja eigentlich bei Milchschnitten am liebsten das Schwarze obendrauf. Mal was anderes, ich war, bevor ich deine Mutter kennengelernt habe, schon verheiratet, aber es war eher so eine Fake-Ehe. Nee, was magst du an den Milchschnitten? Genau, ich mag es lieber, äh, keine Nachfrage, etwa. Wie, und dann den Podcast erzählen, und dann mein Vater von den Milchschnitten erzählen, und weisst du, was ich beim liebbsten genau, aber gar nicht darauf eingehen will, auf den spannenden Pfad. Ich reich's nach, wie gesagt. Genau, und ich habe herausgefunden, meine Mutter hat ein konkretes Ziel im Leben. Und so denkst du, okay, krass, wow. Ich bin so gespannt. Man denkt ja oft über seine Eltern nicht so ganz als Menschen. Also schon als Menschen, aber nicht so als, okay, die stehen so über allem und die haben dir alles beigebracht, aber die haben halt auch persönliche Bedürfnisse und wollen halt Sachen machen und haben Träume und sowas.
Und das wird einem dann bewusst in dem Moment. Und ich dachte mir so, was kommt jetzt irgendwie so, meine Mutter will nochmal nach Indien fliegen oder will nochmal tauchen. Und meine Mutter hat gesagt, ja, mein Traum wäre es, ich würde gerne das Bernsteinzimmer finden. Kein schlechtes Ziel, gar nicht. Aber ich dachte jetzt, dass da eher was... Aber hat sie dafür irgendwas schon mal getan in ihrem Leben? Gar nicht! Hat sie irgendwas an ihrem Lebensstil bislang verraten können, dass sie dieses Band-Shot im Zimmerverhand noch mal finden will? finden will. Also mir ist es noch nicht aufgefallen. Gibt's in eurem Haus. Aber wie lange warst du schon mal in der Garage und hast dann so roten Bindfäden, an der irgendwo stehen so russische Zeitungsartikel oder sowas? Ja, und dann habe ich auch gesagt, okay, ich würde gerne das Bernsteinzimmer finden. Suchst du denn auch danach? Ja, suchst du aktiv noch das Bandschelzimmer. Und dann ist sie so, ja, nicht genug. Also wenn ihr zu mir darüber nachdenkt, wo ist das nicht genug, da hast du recht. Und vor allem, ich habe wirklich mit allem gerechnet, aber nicht mit so einem Indiana-Jones-Abenteuer-Ding irgendwie. Das ist ein cooles Ziel, das ist eigentlich geil. Ich finde gerne das Grab, tut er nicht Armut. Das muss man immer ausheben. Was? Wie bitte? Ja, okay, aber das hat es irgendwie fasziniert, weil ich habe dann auch mal ein bisschen recherchiert, das wurde irgendwann mal... Aber wenn Sie das finden, das wäre die beste Geschichte. Das wäre so gut, das wäre so gut, wenn ich einmal sage. Weil einmal hat das als Lebensziel, manche haben das so als Job oder sowas. Keine Ahnung, ich weiss nicht genau, aber dann, das war ja irgendwie, keine Ahnung, musste irgendwas evakuiert werden und dann wurde das alles in Kisten verpackt. Und dann, das ist das Letzte, was man weiss, man weiss nicht genau, wo diese Kisten sind. Und meine Mutter hat auch gesagt, die müssen ja irgendwo sein, Kisten sind ja nicht... Da hast du auch gesagt, da bist du was auf der Spur. Ja, das ist gut, ich geh dem mal nach. Geh dem mal, geh mal irgendwas nach. Und ich bin sehr, sehr gespannt, was daraus nach. Hat sie da irgendwie Artikel drüber gelesen schon mal oder so, hat sie irgendwie einen Schritt in die Richtung gewagt? Ich wollte sie jetzt nicht so callen, so im Sinne von so, was hast du schon dazu gemacht? Ne, sehr, was hast du denn so der Familie am Weihnachtstisch, ne, die halten wir nicht an die Klappe. Was hast du nun mal dafür getan? Was hast du jemals für das Bernsteinzimmer getan, Mama? Ja, jemals. Und ich weiß nicht, ob sie konkrete Hinweise hat, ich weiß auch nicht, ob sie mir das anvertrauen würde. Oder das ist ihr Humor. Das ist ihr Humor. Vielleicht werden sie dich einfach verarschen. Vielleicht, unsere Eltern alle sehr lustig, aber wir verstehen den Humor nicht. Man weiss es auch nicht genau. Vielleicht war vieles davon ironisch gemeint. Aber ich glaube, irgendwann mal, sag ich mal so, pass auf, wir gehen jetzt mal zusammen auf die Suche, wir fahren nach Russland und suchen mal nach Kissen. Guck mal, was wir finden, wir schauen einfach mal, vielleicht finden wir welche und vielleicht finden wir einen Teil. Aber das ist so faszinierend, wie anders unsere Eltern sind. Ja, ja, als wir zum Beispiel. Ich höre da auch viele Parallelen draus. Ja, ich war meine Mutter in Köln so lange Zeit mal wieder und wir sind auf diesen E-Rollern gefahren. Zu zweit auf einer? Nee, nee, nee, ihr hattet einen eigenen bekommen. Man kann bei Laim auch so eine Gruppenfahrt machen, da habe ich ihr den freigeschaltet und so. Dumme Idee vielleicht auch einfach. Und sie ist ja nicht mehr die Jüngste und ist dann auf diesem Rollhack rumgeflitzt, weil es ganz lustig war. Und dann ist sie aber, was mich dann sehr wütend gemacht hat als energetischer Sohn, war dann, dass sie sehr langsam gefahren ist. Und zwar lächerlich langsam hinter mir her gefahren ist und ich dann so auch mal nach hinten geguckt habe und dann ist ja dieser prüfende Blick so, wo bleibt der Kumpel hinter einem Pferd und so, meine Mutter war aber weg. Und dann irgendwann am Horizont erschien sie dann und fuhr dann langsam herbei und dann Und auch keinen Dopplereffekt zu hören, weil der Schall sagt, Leute. Zu langsam für den Schall. Ja, und dann war ich so ein bisschen sauer, weil ich dachte, komm, du musst noch mal ein bisschen Adrenalin, ein bisschen was parken in deinem Leben. Hast du keinen Traum, Bernstein zu finden oder so? Du musst noch mal ein bisschen was auf so einem Scooter, das ist doch was cooles. Das gab's doch bei euch damals nicht. So, dann reiss doch jetzt mal mit und erkunde Köln, fahr, fahr. Aber dann war sie halt sehr langsam, da habe ich sie so ein bisschen was mit dem Leiter angemacht, aber sie hätten auch gehen können jetzt, weil dafür habe ich jetzt 5,20 Euro bezahlt. Nee, das muss nicht sein. Für diese Fahrt von einer U-Bahn-Station zur anderen. So, vielen Dank, das ist jetzt weg, das Geld. Und dann war ich auch so ein bisschen sauer. Am nächsten Tag hat sie mich angerufen und hat dann gesagt, ich habe da jetzt gestern nochmal den ganzen Abend darüber nachgedacht, ob du da jetzt recht hattest mit. Du hast mich ja dann schon ziemlich berichtigt da, aber ich habe da die ganze Nacht darüber nachgedacht und ich bin zu dem bin zu dem Schluss gekommen, dass du nicht recht hattest. Überraschung! Und ich dachte mir auch so, nein, das tut mir auch leid, das hat niemand kommt. Dann hat sie gesagt, nee, ich habe noch mal nachgedacht, weil es war ja auch schon dunkel. Stimmt, das habe ich ja erzählen können in der Grieche. Es war ja schon dunkel und man sieht ja auch nicht alle Bodenwellen und so. Und ich dachte mir so, der rationale Mensch, der doch irgendwo in mir existiert, dachte mir so, ja, guter Punkt eigentlich. Und so diese kleine Lampe da vorne, die macht auch, hilft einem auch nicht so wirklich. Und da waren ja auch sehr viele Menschen und du bist zwischen denen einfach hin und her geschlängelt, so. Und dann kann denen ja auch was passieren, da waren ja auch Kinder dabei, die manchmal vielleicht Bewegungen machen, die man nicht so vorhersehen kann. Und da hatte ich auch dann keinen Punkt mehr, muss man sagen. Und sie hatte dann auch recht. Bis, und ich dachte mir, ja gut, aber ich feiere auch schon ein bisschen länger jetzt, bis ich vor zwei Tagen abends sehr schnell gefahren bin und mich dermaßen hingelegt habe. Zum ersten Mal habe ich mich so hingelegt, und ich hoffe, dass meine Mutter diesen Podcast niemals hört, weil sie das nicht erfahren hat, aber ich habe mich so dermaßen aus dem Haul gelegt, das kann man sich nicht vorstellen, weil es war wirklich sehr dunkel, stoppfinster und man ist gefahren und ich habe einfach einen Bordstein nicht gesehen und dann bin ich wirklich über den Lenker drüber und das war vor zwei Tagen und ich merke nichts. Ich habe nirgendwo einen blauen Fleck, ich weiss nicht, was passiert ist, hinter mir standen dann zwei Freunde, die einfach nur laut gelacht haben und gestaunt haben, wahnsinnig erstaunt waren, weil ich mich wohl so geschickt abgerollt habe, weil an irgendeinem Punkt, und es ging in meinem Kopf alles sehr langsam, so ein bisschen Matrix-artig, bin ich über den Lenker, habe mich dann so abgerollt, dass ich wirklich, ich merke nirgendwo was, ich habe auch nirgendwo irgendeine kleinen blauen Flecken oder so, ich merke nichts, ich musste auch selber lachen und ich stand danach auch wieder, ich weiß auch nicht, wie das ging, ich bin über den Lenker gegangen, habe mich abgerollt und stand dann und wir haben gesagt, wo haben die das gesehen? Wie cool, wie cool, das sind Momente, wo ich dachte, geil, ja, nee, manchmal ist die Realität nicht pädagogisch genug, einfach so, wo du denkst, ich hätte, ich hätte jetzt eigentlich bestraft werden müssen, aber es ist einfach nichts passiert. Das ist so oft, wie ich Sachen auch einfach zu lange liegen lasse und keine Konsequenzen spüren. Ne, das stimmt. Du musst den Steuern, brauchst du gar nicht erwähnen andauernd, du wirst irgendwann die Konsequenzen spüren. Ne, ich so nicht, ich frage, wann du in den Knast kommst, morgen oder in einem Jahr, es kann beides sein. Sie müssen das jetzt zahlen, Sie müssen das jetzt unbedingt zahlen und dann nie wieder was davon gehört. Sollte man das hier auch nicht wechseln. Ich muss es unbedingt die Rauchmelder bei mir wechseln lassen. Das war nämlich der schlimmste Tag meines Lebens. Ich hatte diese schreckliche Nacht mit den Rückenschmerzen und dann natürlich, sobald die Sonne aufgeht, gehen die Rückenschmerzen weg, wo der Körper einfach sagt, das fick dich einfach. Fuck you. Das war einfach so, das war jetzt mal eine Lektion von mir an dich. Und dann denkst du dir, okay, ich muss irgendwie wach werden. Meine Idee, um wach zu werden, war, heiss zu duschen. So, das war meine Idee, ist nicht die beste in der Welt. Wach zu werden? Heiss zu duschen? Du merkst aber wohl das Problem mit dieser Idee ist. Ja, ich dachte immer so, okay, ich muss jetzt meinen Körper irgendwie in eine Art von Notsituation bringen, um wach zu werden, also dusche ich heiß.
Also dusche ich heiß, dusche mich da ab und es macht immer heißer und es gibt ja so diese Temperatur, die am Anfang noch viel zu heiß war, ist irgendwann okay. Und dann machst du noch heißer und dann machst du den Hummer-Effekt, wo du einfach denkst, bin ich schön durch irgendwie, weil irgendwann ist es heiß. Und dann dusche ich mich da heiß ab und das komplette Bad voller Dampf und so und plötzlich geht der Rauchmelder los.
What? Weil du verbrannt bist langsam. Ich habe so heiß geduscht anscheinend, dass von dem Dampf der Rauchmelder angegangen ist und ich natürlich in Panik spring aus der Dusche, renn nass, nackt und fett. Brennend, renn auch brennend aus der Dusche. Ich renne nass wie ein fetter Blitz einfach durch die Wohnung, spring an die Decke, versuche den Rauchmelder auszudrücken, keine Chance, stumme Finger sind zu kurz, spring da rum, hol ihn, es war wirklich so erbärmlich einfach, hol ihn nach dem Stuhl, kletter hoch, mach den aus, krieg ihn nicht auch und reiss ihn wirklich gewaltsam von der, einfach weil ich denke, es muss jetzt einfach aufhören, weil es so inben Uhr morgens ist oder so, reiss ihn von der Decke und dann dachte ich mir, das ist der schlimmste Tag meines Lebens. Wenn du mal panisch, wirklich nackt und fett durch die Gegend gerannt bist, dann nenne ich mir so, okay, jetzt bin ich wach, also jetzt bin ich einfach wach. Oh, ey, der Plan ist aufgegangen, wenn der jetzt Tag ist. Ich habe den Rauchmelder ausgemacht, angeschrieben und in eine Schublade getan und weggetragen.
Oder war die Batterie einfach weg?
War die Batterie leer?
Kann auch, ich glaube nicht.
Ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen. Ich habe das mit Ratscht ja nicht aus, dann machen die einmal Piep.
Ja, ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen.
Aber die Abstände sind nicht optimal.
Auch eine Kritik an den Herstellern von Feuermeldern.
Die Abstände des Pieps sind nicht optimal.
Du hast einen Piep, dann merkst du, okay, irgendwo in der Wohnung ist ein Rauchmelder,
aufsichtlich leer. Dann wartest du aufs nächste Piep, dann viel zu lange auch und so, so lange, dass du schon wieder ein anderes Geräusch machen könntest und das Piep überhören könntest wieder. So, dann kommt es wieder, dann weisst du ungefähr, wo es ist, aber der Abstand ist nicht optimal. Es sollte schneller, die Intervalle sollten kürzer sein. Dann kann man eher den Rauchmelder finden in der Wohnung. Ist dann wie so ein Piep, habe ich mir das eingebautet? Ja. Piep, was ist das, und du kommst niederhinter, weil es nicht schräg genug in der Null ist. Beim dritten Piep denkst du, okay, irgendwas will mir etwas sagen. Ja, aber ich bin stolz, von mir sagen zu können, dass ich so heiß geduscht habe, dass es einem Notfall gleich kam und mein Rauchmelder gesagt hat, Rauchd Dampf, Rauch, Dampf, fuck it, ich mach jetzt einfach mal. Fuck it, es ist zu viel, ich mach einfach mal. Oh, spannend. Weiss man auch nicht genau. Vielleicht war es ein Dampfmelder. Gibt es eine Unterschiede zwischen Rauch und Dampf? Ja. Ach, Stefan. Dampf ist rein, wir haben D doch schon hinter uns. Scheiss auf D. Dampf ist rein, Wasser, oder Keine Ahnung, ich weiss es nicht genau, es hat auf jeden Fall sehr weh getan. Ja. Wütend, einfach der schlechteste Lehrer der Welt. Dampf ist Wasser, oder? Ja, ja, ja, der liegt okay, ja! Mein Gott, nächstes Thema. Aber es war ein ... Der Dampf ist rein Wasser. Ja Rampf ist rein Wasser. Das war ein Rampf ist rein Wasser. Das war ein Rampf ist rein Wasser. Aber Rauch sind ja wahrscheinlich Partikel, die verbrennen. Ich weiss es nicht. Ich weiss nur, dass ich heute einen sehr guten Rauchteegenossen habe. Und ich habe mir auch nachgedacht. Okay. Also der wurde geräuchert tatsächlich. Hä? Verrückt für alle, die das denken, what? Der Tee wurde geräuchert und im Grunde ist es egal, welchen Tee man räuchert, weil es schmeckt halt einfach nach Lagerfeuer. Rauch. Es schmeckt einfach nach Rauch und du schmeckst einfach, ist das ein gesunder Geschmack? Du weißt es nicht, aber... Klingt ganz geil eigentlich. Es klingt richtig geil, vor allem ist es ja spannend. Ich kenne nicht, dass es in der Teephase zu irgendwas führt, aber das ist schon fast wert gewesen. Vergiftung, es gibt ja auch Sachen, wenn man sie als Tee trinkt, dass sie nicht vergiften, und viele Dinge soll man auch gar nicht machen, die man sonst machen kann. Aber weiter habe ich es nicht gelesen, ich habe nur gehört, das ist immer so, ja das soll man ja nicht machen, ja ich weiß nicht, um es geht. Ja gerade habe ich auch, ja das ist auch so ein Internetding neuerdings, weil man so viel liest und so, und man hat dieses Nein-Gag-Wegwisch, diesen Automatismus in sich drin mittlerweile schon. Gerade habe ich im Taxi, weil ihr habt es gesehen,
dass hierher, haben Taxifahrer haben jetzt hier neuerdings so Touchscreen-Dinger und da stand,
auf Trump wurde Kopfgeld ausgesetzt. Ich habe diese Überschrift gelesen und nicht weiter gelesen, wo man auch sagt, was muss eine Überschrift leisten noch, wie spannend muss eine Überschrift noch sein,
damit ich den Artikel lese, zumindest diesen ersten dreizeiligen Text, der noch dick gedruckt ist, weil er mir sagen muss, in mir stehen schon alle wichtigen Informationen, die du brauchst. Aber selbst das war mir, selbst die Händler hat mir nicht gereicht. Und du läufst den ganzen Tag verwirrt durch die Gegend, weil du nur so einen Brocken weißt und einfach den Rest nicht, du weißt einfach nicht genau, worum es geht. Wurde Trump jetzt ein Kopfgeld ausgesetzt? Hast du das von Trump gehört? Ja, auf dem wurde er jetzt ein Kopfgeld ausgesetzt. Ja, das habe ich auch gehört, auf dem wurde ein Kopfgeld ausgesetzt. Weißt du von wem? Weißt du, weißt du, ob du das Mac-Menü willst oder das große, was du... Die, ja, ich glaube, ich nehme wieder den Mac-Rip wie jedes Mal. Aber zurück zu Trump, auf den Kopfgeld ausgesetzt wurde.
Also von wie hoch?
Jeder kann nicht auf dich ein Kopfgeld aufsetzen?
Über 20 Euro, fangen wir bei 20 Euro an.
Wir schauen mal, wie nächste Woche die Folge läuft und dann gucken wir, wie es läuft.
20 Euro bin ich beobachtet.
Ich glaube, bei 20 macht noch niemand, geht noch niemand ein Mord.
Ich glaube, ja.
Was war der billigste Mord, der jemals stattgefunden hat?
Irgendwie so ein Fünfer oder einfach so. Ich weiss nicht genau. Ich weiss nicht. Ich bin nicht im Deep Web aktiv. Ich möchte Ihnen die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frage, dass die Frageen, ich glaube, ja. Was war der billigste Mord, der jemals stattgefunden hat? Irgendwie so ein Fünfer oder einfach so. Ich weiss nicht genau. Ich weiss nicht. Ich bin nicht im Deep Web aktiv. Ich auch nicht. Gut. Ja, aber ihr könnt vielleicht jetzt einen wunderschönen Abend im Deep Web veranstalten. Wir bedanken uns sehr herzlich, dass ihr gekommen seid. Vielen Dank, Hamburg. Es hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Es war fantastisch. Vielen Dank, Hamburg. Dankeschön. Wir stehen da draußen. Genau, wer Lust hat, noch ein Foto oder sonstiges, wir stehen draußen am Merch. Vielen Dank fürs Rundgau. Vielen Dank fürs Korn und Stefan, das ist auch ganz wichtig. Und vielen Dank an Stefan Tietze. Vielen Dank für die Führung. Vielen Dank für die Führung. Vielen Dank für die Führung. Macht's gut, wir sind uns auf und wir heben ab!
Ein Schulte, das ist jedes Mal! Thank you.